David Boder: [In English] Paris, Sep...September the 7th, 1946, at the Grand Hotel. The interviewee is Ms. Fira Monk, a secretary in the Paris office of the ORT. Ms. Monk speaks a very satisfactory French and English, but she—her maternal tongue is...is Russian. And we prefer to take the interview in Russian.
David Boder: [In Russian] Эээ...Фира Яковлевна, скажите-ка ещё раз, как Вас зовут и что Ваше место тут в Париже, и что Вы сейчас делаете?
Fira Monk: Меня зовут Фира Монк. Я работаю в офисе [неразборчиво], делаю приблизительно [неразборчиво] работу. Кроме того, я ещё социальная ассистентка—то, что французы называют ласистен сосиаль [говорит по-французски]. Я делаю...
David Boder: То, что мы по-английски называем social worker.
Fira Monk: Да, это так.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Я говорю [неразборчиво] с людьми, которые к нам записываются и которые не работают в нашей школе. Для этого у нас есть другая ассистентка. [Неразборчиво, помехи] детей, которых мы помещаем в частные [неразборчиво, помехи]
David Boder: Так. Вы говорите «детей». Какого возраста эти дети?
Fira Monk: Мы называем детьми всех, которые к нам приходят—до 22 лет.
David Boder: А фактически, с какого возраста Вы их имеете?
Fira Monk: Мы их имеем от 14 лет. Это дети, которые закончили своё первоначальное образование, или которые [неразборчиво, сильные помехи].
David Boder: Так. ОРТ имеет, значит, двоякую работу: или обучение в собственных мастерских, или так сказать,...или помещение во выучку частными, значит, ремесленниками.
Fira Monk: Да. У нас теперь очень большой запрос на различные ремёсла, которые мы, к сожалению, не можем сами [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Т.е. запросы с чьей стороны?
Fira Monk: Со стороны молодёжи.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Или от взрослых людей, которые хотят реквалифицироваться. Которые хотят получить какое-нибудь профессиональное образование—это врачи, адвокаты и различные люди, которые были депортированы или которые...или беженцы вообще.
David Boder: И они что, значит, хотят реквалифицироваться? Вместо врачей они хотят...
Fira Monk: Во Франции, как вообще, кажется, [неразборчиво] за границей, человек с иностранным дипломом не может практиковать. Здесь врач или юрист с иностранным дипломом—немецким, русским, чешским—должен сделать [неразборчиво, очень тихо], должен пойти в [неразборчиво] и должен получить...сделать [неразборчиво]. И тогда только, если ему повезёт, он получает статус на работу.
David Boder: Так.
David Boder: [In English] The recording is not very efficient. We are now changing a little bit our arrangement.
David Boder: [In Russian] Теперь скажите мне вот что: как давно Вы во Франции?
Fira Monk: Я во Франции с 1926 года. Но мы приехали из России в конце 21-го года, провели какое-то время в Австрии, где я окончила гимназию, и потом моя мать была переведена в Париж на работу.
David Boder: Угу. Что значит «переведена»?
Fira Monk: Она работала...она заведовала фабрикой принадлежностей для пишущих машин в Вене. Эта фабрика была закрыта, её патрон переехал в Париж,...
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: . . . и в благодарность за ту работу, которую моя мать сделала безвозмездно, он её пере...перевёл в Париж, и когда я сделала все свои нужные экзамены, я приехала сюда тоже.
David Boder: Зачем мама делала работу безвозмездно [неразборчиво]?!
Fira Monk: Моя мать—старая идеалистка и старая социалистка. Её шеф не имел денег ей платить, она даже зашила карманы [говорит со смехом].
David Boder: Угу. [Пауза] Хорошо. Теперь скажите нам...скажите, что...где Вы были, и что произошло с Вами, и с ОРТом, когда началась война.
Fira Monk: Мы были в стадии, уже во время начала войны. 9 сентября 39-го года мы переехали всем бюро в Виши. Там мы были до января 40-го года, всё время так называемой «крё де гер» [говорит по-французски]—это была война без пушечного выстрела, когда солдаты сидели в окопах и вообще не знали, зачем они там сидят. В январе мы переехали обратно в Париж, было спокойно. Мы жили там до 7 июня, 40-го года. 7 июня нам предложили всем уехать...
David Boder: Кто вам предложил?
Fira Monk: [Неразборчиво] У нас...эээ...мы получили известие, что немцы уже приближаются к Парижу, что Париж скоро будет взят. Нам даже было очень трудно верить, лично мне! Я не хотела верить. Я спорила со своими старшими коллегами, не хотела ни за что уезжать. Но они настаивали, и на следующий день я поняла, что правы были они. Потому что друзья мои и другие мои коллеги, уехавшие на два-три дня позже, уже имели страшные неприятности: они должны были перепрыгивать через стены лионского вокзала, для того чтобы попасть на поезд. Другие ездили 10 дней автомобилем под обстрелом этой...ммм...авиации и пулемётов, и вообще [неразборчиво]. Мы переехали в Виши, и мы там жили...покуда приехали немцы.
David Boder: Т.е. как? Вы были, значит, в Виши, когда в Виши был Петен?
Fira Monk: А! Мы были в Виши до Петена. Петен за нами последовал. Он, очевидно, не мог без нас жить. Петен...
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Петен приехал в...после перемирия.
Fira Monk: Он ещё свою речь—я не помню уже точно, где он держал свою речь, кажется, это не было в Виши,—но мы его речь слушали, обливаясь горючими слезами. Мы знали тогда, что начинается такая, не совсем приятная, полоса нашей жизни. И мы жили в Виши до конца 40-го года, когда нас очень вежливо, но довольно настойчиво, попросили убраться восвояси.
David Boder: Т.е.?
Fira Monk: Т.е. нам сказали, что еврейской организации не место рядом с Лавалем.
David Boder: Ага.
Fira Monk: И...но я Лаваля очень часть встречала на улице. Вид у него был довольно несимпатичный. Он был похож на плохого метрдотеля из плохого кафе. И мы переехали в Марсель. Нашли там очень хорошее помещение, и мы там жили.
David Boder: Так. Скажите, между прочим,...скажите между прочим, кто был с Вами с Вашей семьи?
Fira Monk: В моей семье тогда были: моя мать, мой приёмный ребёнок, моя бабушка,...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Fira Monk: . . . Филипп, моя бабушка, моя тётя, две сестры моей матери, и её шурин—это самая семья.
David Boder: Так. Эээ...кто Ваш приёмный ребёнок?
Fira Monk: Мой приёмный ребёнок—очаровательный испанчонок. Мы его взяли ещё в 37-ом году во время испанской войны. Взяли мы его на три недели, но мы к нему так привязались, что вообще не может быть никакой речи о том, чтобы мы отдали ребёнка.
David Boder: Скажите, а кто его привёз к Вам?
Fira Monk: Привё...эээ...это было так: когда началась испанская война, моя мать внесла своим товарищам по партии предложение, чтоб привезли в Париж, не только в провинции, испанских детей, которых спасали партии от бомбардировок.
David Boder: Это что? Какая партия? Социал...
Fira Monk: Социал-демократическая, конечно.
David Boder: Французская?
Fira Monk: Французская, да. Но она была в партии и в Австрии, и в...
David Boder: . . . во Франции?
Fira Monk: Да. И ещё в России она была в партии!
David Boder: Ну, да. [Пауза] И вот?
Fira Monk: Ну, значит, мы тогда приняли ребёнка на несколько недель. Мы к нему очень привязались, этот ребёнок теперь наш. Им будет заниматься и мама, и я—старшая сестра, не смотря на маленькую разницу лет—ему теперь 14. Он очень способный, он очень красивый. Он очень к нам привязан.
David Boder: Так. А вся его беда в общем, и что известно о его родителях?
Fira Monk: Его родители живы.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: У них там ещё трое детей. Один во Франции, в семье одной английской барышни находится его старший брат—он на три года старше его. Семья очень разорена во время войны, его отец потерял правую руку. Он был электротехником, имел свой большой гараж. Мать—...ммм...учительница в детском саду. И очевидно, она не может работать. Старшая девочка ходит на фабрику, второй мальчик пасёт коров. И отец написал, что...зная, что мы можем дать ребёнку лучшее воспитание, образование, чем он, разорённые этими фашистами, и он просит нас держать ребёнка до совершеннолетия.
David Boder: А где отец?
Fira Monk: Отец находится в Испании—не то в Бильбао, не то в каком-то другом городе.
David Boder: Он в войну [неразборчиво]
Fira Monk: Да, да. [Неразборчиво]
David Boder: Он не уезжал?
Fira Monk: Нет, нет, он не уезжал. Он [неразборчиво] боролся на стороне Красной Армии.
David Boder: Так. [Пауза] Теперь скажите: значит, вы все переехали из Виши куда?
Fira Monk: Мы значит...моя мать и Филипп—мы переехали в Марсель. А моя бабушка, две сестры и шурин моей матери переехали в Ниццу. Они там жили. Это была так называемая свободная зона. В 42-ом году, когда мы были ещё в Марселе, была довольно спокойная жизнь, хорошая работа. ОРТ открыл там очень красивую большую школу. Мы надеялись, что всё-таки как-нибудь мы это всё проделаем, начались депортации.
David Boder: Так. Из свободной зоны?
Fira Monk: Из свободной зоны.
David Boder: Значит, я хочу это установить. Депортации евреев или [неразборчиво] не евреев?
Fira Monk: Нет, неевреев брали по политическому признаку.
David Boder: Так вот, депортация евреев началась из неокупаемой зоны...
Fira Monk: . . . в 42-ом году,...
David Boder: Т.е. прежде...
Fira Monk: . . . в августе 1942...
David Boder: Да, да, да, в 42-ом году. Когда же немцы заняли всю Францию? Они её заняли...
Fira Monk: В ноябре.
David Boder: -...как только Америка вступила в войну?
Fira Monk: Немцы заняли всю Францию в 1942 году в ноябре.
David Boder: Не в 41-ом году?!
Fira Monk: Нет, они заняли...в 40-ом году они заняли северную часть. В Виши, в Мулене была демаркационная линия, за которой кончалась их власть. А начиная от Мулена до юга Франции—это была свободная зона, где у нас было французское правительство.
David Boder: Хорошо. Значит, депортации начались после того, как американский посол уехал из Виши?
Fira Monk: Амер...я не помню, когда уехал посол...
David Boder: Мы начали...вступили в войну с Перл-Харбор в 42-ом году, в 41-ом году.
Fira Monk: В 41-ом. А это было после того, что он уехал.
David Boder: Значит, это было уже после того, как он уехал, и американского консульства...
Fira Monk: . . . уже не было.
David Boder: . . . уже не было.
Fira Monk: Нет, уже не было. Но, тем не менее, американские, английские евреи, турецкие евреи, венгерские и румынские были под защитой—их не депортировали. Их только гораздо позже депортировали с севера Франции, с Парижа.
David Boder: Так. Ну, а Ваш лично [неразборчиво] депортации?
Fira Monk: В начале августа 42-го года—я как раз тогда была больна и лежала в постели—из марсельской префектуры пришёл ко мне человек, который сказал мне: «Мадам Монк, будьте добры, предупредите всех ваших знакомых, которых Вы только знаете, которых Вы не знаете о том, что на днях, во вторник»,—я не помню числа—«начнутся общие меры против евреев. Будьте осторожны. Пусть все прячутся, кто может и куда может».
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Я сейчас же послала мою мать в контору предупредить собратьев. Наши были немножко удивлены, направили человека, разузнали и действительно узнали, что это так. А вначале мы даже думали, что это какой- то слух: что это за...
David Boder: А кто, Вы говорите, «наши»?
Fira Monk: Наши—это ОРТ, это моя вторая семья.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: [Кашляет] И мы разослали гонца во все стороны Марселя, предупредили людей, кого могли. Но, к сожалению, очень многие из наших друзей попались, потому что они были в лагере под Марселем [неразборчиво, по-французски]. И это была мышеловка: там захлопнулась дверь, и от...оттуда уже никто не мог...
David Boder: Т.е., каким образом они были в лагере?
Fira Monk: В лагерь сажали всех австрийских, немецких евреев, вообще всех евреев враждующих стран. И они там сидели в страшных условиях, в грязи, без воды и отвратительно питались. ОРТ и ОЗЕ делали для них всё, что могли.
David Boder: ОЗЕ?
Fira Monk: ОЗЕ.
David Boder: Это общество о...
Fira Monk: . . . о здравоохранении евреев.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Мы работали тогда очень тесно связанными. И мы делали всё, что мы могли. Офис был [неразборчиво] на работы. Чтоб они не сидели просто без работы, ведь это страшно на них действовало с точки зрения моральности.
David Boder: И вот, Вы предупредили своих знакомых, и что случилось тогда?
Fira Monk: И тогда случилось просто, что ночью началась облава. Это было не во вторник, как нам сказал наш префектурный друг, а это случилось в четверг ночью. Окружили немцы несколько кварталов. Это была французская жандармерия и французская гард-мобиль. Они приходили за людьми и говорили: «Соберите столько вещей, сколько вы можете взять с собой—вы арестованы,—носить с собой,—вы арестованы». Были страшные сцены: люди выбрасывались из окон, кончали с собой. Но французская полиция была на высоте—она очень часто в случаях, где она могла, она предупреждала людей заранее, или она даже...я знаю лично случай, когда пришёл французский жандарм в сопровождении своего коллеги к одной женщине и сказал ей: «Я приду через 15 минут». Эта женщина не поняла. Она собрала все свои вещи и мирно села на стуле ждать. Когда через 15 минут вернулся этот же самый городовой, он ей сказал: «Позвольте, я ж Вам сказал, что буду обратно через пятнадцать [говорит медленно] минут». Тогда эта женщина поняла. И она сказала: «Я ещё не совсем готова. Я Вас прошу, придите через 10 минут». И [неразборчиво] 10 минут и ушла, больше не было. Но люди не знали. Мы вообще не верили во всё это. Мы думали, что людей будут ссылать на работы, но не думали, что их посадят в гетто. И когда была забрана моя семья—я, правда, перевернула небо и землю, я ничего не могла сделать, никто не мог ничего сделать. Мы не верили в то, что нам говорила английская пропаганда по радио. Мы не верили в то, что нам потом писали оттуда. Мы думали, что это всё пропаганда.
David Boder: Так. Скажите-ка, кого из Вашей семьи взяли? И как это случилось?
Fira Monk: Это случилось как раз таки потому, что мой дядя очень верил во...эээ...французскую систему, во французскую честность, если Вы хотите. Он приехал сюда иностранцем, значит, в 39-ом году и...
David Boder: Откуда?
Fira Monk: Из Вены. Он там имел очень большой магазин, даже фабрику, мужского платья. Был состоятельный человек. И очень умный человек. Хотела Вам это подчеркнуть, чтобы Вы поняли будущее. Но ввиду того, что он был очень честный человек, он никогда не мог понять несправедливость человеческую, грязь человеческую. И когда...он должен был продлевать свою карт де ла сите—ресиписе каждые три месяца. Его ресиписе закончилось 31 августа, 1942 года.
David Boder: Что закончилось?
Fira Monk: Ресиписе—это бумага, которая заменяет...ммм...
David Boder: . . . паспорт.
Fira Monk: . . . французский паспорт. Право жительства
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Я писала им: «Господа, я предупреждена тем-то и тем-то человеком, что произойдёт то-то и то-то. Будьте осторожны. Мальвиночка»,—это сестра моей матери,—«больна. У неё жёлчный камень. Ей необходимо пойти в санаторий». Санаторием мы называли место скрытия. Он не верил. Приходили мои друзья к нему в Ниццу и говорили: «[неразборчиво] не идите, опасно. Вы попадётесь». Он не поверил. Он взял мою бабушку—за бумагами ей 80 лет, в самом деле, ей теперь только 76, и эту бедную мою вторую тётю—она была парализована, когда ей было 8 лет после дифтерита. Он с ними вместе пошёл. Они стояли в очереди два часа. Это только так кажется, что он был единственный такой доверчивый человек. Через два часа их всех...
David Boder: Какой человек?
Fira Monk: Он не был единственный! Никто не мог себе представить, что французская полиция будет так действовать. Через два часа их арестовали. Бабушку моментально освободили. А мою бедную парализованную тётю, и мою здоровую тётю, Мальвиночку, жену его, сейчас же арестовали. Они ещё через два часа вернулись в сопровождении двух французских полицейских, и она тогда сказала: «Мамочка, всё кончено». Их посадили в казарму, в Ницце. Они...
David Boder: А дядю Вашего?
Fira Monk: Тоже. Он тогда ещё был с ними. Они были в Ницце, потом их перевели в лагерь на юге Франции, возле испанской границы Ривсант? [название по-французски]. [Пауза] Солёная река—очевидно, она солена от еврейских слёз.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: И они там сидели ещё несколько дней. Мы старались всячески...Тогда там был Канарский, Яков Александрович. Он старался всячески! Я ему телеграфировала. Мы старались выдать ему удостоверение [неразборчиво], который тогда входил в ОРТ. Что я раб...что я секретарша общества, что они мои родные, что нужно их спасти—это всё ничего не помогло. Дядю по возрасту—ему был 61 год, и тогда ещё брали людей только до 60 лет. Здоров он, нездоров—это не играло никакой роли. Были определённые категории, которых не брали. Например, люди с детьми французскоподанными, или же которые...эээ...имели какие-нибудь заслуги на прошлой войны...войне, эти...ммм...добровольцы, и люди после 60 лет. Тогда мой дядя написал письмо. Нам. И писал нам, что не знает, что ему делать: делать ему голосу разума или сердца. Мы ему ответили, чтоб он поступил так, как он понял.
David Boder: Что он подразумевал под этим—«голос разума»?
Fira Monk: Голос разума—это значит выйти, пойти на свободу, голос сердца...
David Boder: А ему можно было выйти?
Fira Monk: Он мог же! Я же Вам говорю: ему был 61 год, и он имел право выйти, он был свободен. Он не подвергался тогда депортации, в тот момент.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Тогда это всё изменилось, брали 95-летних людей тоже.
Fira Monk: Он мог даже посещать синагогу. Он был очень набожный человек. Он пошёл, и раввин ему сказал: «Делай как хочешь. Я тебе не судья». И он понял, что должен пойти за той женщиной, с которой он провёл всю свою жизнь...
David Boder: . . . пойти за своей женой?
Fira Monk: За своей женой, да. [Смеётся] он её обожал, он за ней ухаживал 7 лет, как Яков ухаживал за Рахилью. Он считал её своей...частью своего тела, своей души, и он понял, что всё равно он не мог бы жить без неё.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: И вот они...их увезли в неизвестном направлении. Я поставила на всём пути...
David Boder: В неизвестном?
Fira Monk: В неизвестном направлении. Я поставила на всём пути ассистентов [неразборчиво], которые им давали еду, пищу, и мы ещё получили несколько писем.
David Boder: Но...но как далеко Вы получали?
Fira Monk: Мы получали письма до Брива.
David Boder: Это где?
Fira Monk: Брив—это в центре Франции.
David Boder: Ага.
Fira Monk: [Неразборчиво] и тётя моя писала: «Я счастлива, что я уезжаю. Мы катимся. Куда—я не знаю, но мы выживем. И Бог будет сильнее смерти». Оказалось, что в данном случае смерть была гораздо сильнее любви. И если бы мы верили, потом я написала письмо в Париж, в Центральный еврейский комитет, чтобы узнать, куда они делись, что с ними стало. Получила ответ, что 17-го сентября 42-го года их увезли в неизвестном направлении.
David Boder: Были они в Дранси?
Fira Monk: Они были в Дранси, но они, к сожалению, были всего один день. Даже не целый день—их сейчас же увезли. Я думаю, что они сейчас же были ликвидированы, потому что моя тетя была больная женщина. Маленькая...я думаю, я надеюсь, я верю в это, что погибла, наверно, по дороге, потому что она не могла перенести этой поездки, в этом скотском вагоне, без воды и стоявши посередине. Ну, а мой дядя, Вы ж понимаете, что долго он тоже не протянул. Человек—62 года, в больными желудками, и вообще как все.
David Boder: Так. Вы не знаете, куда они попали? Никаких сведений...
Fira Monk: Никаких решительно. Я потом работала для Министерства депортированных и военнопленных. И все бумаги, которые заполняла, все запросы, которые я сделала, остались без всякого результата. Боялись ли они рисковать, я не знаю. Я думаю, что они просто не знали. Потому что я как-то получила сведения, что один конвой 42-го года при [неразборчиво] был целиком уничтожен. И я хочу надеяться, что они попали именно в этот конвой. Потому что, мне, как ни странно, гораздо приятнее мысль о том, что они погибли сейчас же, что их сейчас же убили, чем мысль о том, что они там промучились несколько лет или несколько месяцев—в этих диких условиях, и только потом нашли бы смерть. [Пауза]
David Boder: Так. Ну, вернёмся теперь обратно. Значит, где Вы были со своей матерью, со своим приёмным...ммм...братом или сыном, и...что там происходило?
Fira Monk: Значит так: когда мы приехали в Марсель—это было в ноябре 41-го года—вместо очаровательного южного солнца мы застали глубокую сибирскую зиму. Конечно, о том, чтобы топили—об этом не могло быть и речи. Это был каменный дом, в котором мы мёрзли. Но потом настала весна, и у нас, как я Вам говорила, была надежда на то, что мы сможем хорошо работать. И мы уже...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Fira Monk: Да, конечно была. И мы там работали [пауза], открыли школу, как я Вам сказала, и ребёнок ходил в школу, он посещал детей. [Пауза] Ну,...а потом, в ноябре 42-го года пришла...эээ...пришли немцы в Марсель. И это было очень неприятно, потому что когда мы услышали немецкие сапоги по марсельским мостовым, нам стало кисло. А, да! Нет, была ещё одна, знаете ли, вещь: когда немцы начали войну с Россией, все русские были арестованы, и это было очень забавно. Я, значит, сидела в бюро. Вдруг телефонный звонок, и мне говорят: «Придите моментально домой». В чём дело, мне не говорят. «Придите, мол, моментально». Ну, я мчусь домой, конечно, пешком, потому что тогда не было никакого другого способа сообщения, трамваи были переполнены, все месили [неразборчиво] ногами. Прихожу домой, спрашиваю хозяина, в чём дело. Он мне говорит: «Нет, ничего, ничего. Ваша мать жива». Я решила, что моя мать выскочила из этого...из окна. Прихожу...с трудом до...дотянула до третьего этажа, выходит какой-то господин. Я спрашиваю: «Что с моей матерью?» Он говорит: «Она жива». Ну, я поняла, что это несчастье. Вхожу, вижу полнейший беспорядок: шкафы раскрыты, ящики выдвинуты, чемоданы распотрошены. Мама стоит в окружении каких-то типов, и они говорят: «Мадам, Вы арестованы». Я говорю: «За что?» Они говорят: «Политическое дело». Когда они сказали «политическое дело», у меня немножечко потемнело в глазах, потому что при мне были письма от разных социалистических друзей, сидевших тогда в тюрьме. И вот я сказала, конечно, что я политическим не занимаюсь. И нас всё-таки на этом попросили, чтоб мы взяли с собой вещей на несколько дней и еды. «Что делать с ребёнком?» Они говорят: «Берите ребёнка с собой». Ну, хорошо. Они нас повезли, правда, очень мило, сами заплатили за свои билеты на трамвай. Вот мы приехали в [говорит по-французски].
David Boder: А кто это они?
Fira Monk: Ммм...эти вот сыщики.
David Boder: Заплатили за Ваши билеты?
Fira Monk: За свои, свои. Мы заплатили за свои, а они платили за свои. Они как сыщики и не имеют право разъезжать бесплатно. Очевидно, хотели, чтобы мы не заметили...чтобы не было заметно, что мы арестованы. И нас привели в [по-французски]. Когда мы пришли в [по-французски], мы увидели там бездонное количество русских, и мы сразу поняли, что нас арестовали как русских. Потом был допрос, причём французы вели себя опять-таки удивительно корректно. [Пауза] Но пов...повели на какой-то пароход, где должен был быть допрос. И люди, которые...которых они считали...ммм...немножко подозрительными с точки зрения политической, были отправлены в лагерь. Но моё счастье было то, что я работала в ОРТе. Значит, у меня уже было...был...такая каменная стена за спиной. Они нас отпустили через 48 часов после [неразборчиво] допроса, который длился три четверти часа...
David Boder: На пароходе?
Fira Monk: На пароходе....в котором принимал участие немец, итальянец, француз. Каждый ставил со своей стороны вопросы. В конце нужно было ответить более менее умеренно, уверенно и не вдаваясь в слишком большие подробности. После того нас отпустили. Это было в июне 41-го года. А в 42-ом году в ноябре, когда немцы пришли в Марсель, нам [неразборчиво] сказали: «Господа, постарайтесь отсюда уехать». И тогда встал вопрос—куда ехать? Что ехать? Зачем ехать? Если мы дальше поедем, что это будет? Какие будут результаты? Немцы могут дальше прийти. Потом мы узнали, что немцы берут определённые города по определённой линии, а что остальная часть Франции будет в итальянском ведении. И мы по совету друзей переехали в Вуарон. Это маленький городок недалеко от Гренобля, 26км. [Пауза]
David Boder: Гренобль на французской стороне?
Fira Monk: Ну, конечно он на французской стороне. Он ещё...
David Boder: Извините мою географию.
Fira Monk: [Смеётся]...он ещё в 200, кажется, км от Женевы.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Это очаровательный город. Ну, наш город—он тоже очень милый городок. Правда, когда мы туда переехали, там было очень большое количество милиционеров. Милиция французская—это равняется немецким СС. Они себя тоже вели довольно...
David Boder: СС или гестапо?
Fira Monk: [Пауза] Я Вам скажу, большой разницы между этими двумя учреждениями нет.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: И те убивали, и те убивали, так что...эээ...какое имя хочешь дай.
David Boder: Угу.
Fira Monk: Это совершенно безразлично. Короче, мы там открыли наше бюро, работали. Мы открыли в Гренобле школу—женскую школу шитья, которую я...туда ехала, значит, следить за тем, чтобы всё было в порядке. И до сентября 43-го года мы жили действительно как [пауза] у Христа за пазухой: спокойно, тихо, никто нас не трогал. Мы были...
David Boder: А где в этот момент был Френкель?
Fira Monk: А Френкель всё время был с нами. Ростиславский? тогда уехал в Швейцарию. Он уехал в январе 43-го года, потому что его пребывание здесь считалось слишком рискованным. И затем мы узнали, что он сделал больше, находясь в Швейцарии, с точки зрения финансовой, и пропагандической [неразборчиво]...
David Boder: Ростиславич? был во Франции?!
Fira Monk: Всегда. Он был во Франции.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Он был...ммм...с 33-го года. С 33-го года он был во Франции.
Fira Monk: И в 43-ем году он уехал в Женеву, а Френкель остался здесь. И, значит, Френкель являлся тогда, естественно, заведующим ОРТа.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Да, и вообще довёл себя до того, что—я Вам должна сказать, что я ничего подобного не видела,—пожил...он сначала хотел...
David Boder: В каком смысле?
Fira Monk: Ну, в смысле героическом!
David Boder: Ага.
Fira Monk: Он никогда—Вы ведь знаете, что там ведь бывали моменты, когда приходили к нам люди из Резистанс и говорили: «Господа, вы должны уйти, вы должны спрятаться»,—Френкель никогда не уходил на свою нелегальную квартиру до тех пор, пока не был уверен, что все сотрудники уже на месте, спрятались. Тогда только он брал свою котомочку и уходил с женой. Правда также в том, что мы все прятались в том же городе, у разных французов, которые к нам совершенно изумительно относились. Они были...не так были в силе семитически настроены, как они были антинацистами. Они считали, что они французы, и немцы ничего не должны делать в их стране. Кроме того, Изер—департамент, в котором мы были, был известен как один из самых главных по Резистанс. Там был [неразборчиво], который сделал чудеса. Это...Вуарон...мы ведь видели с большой дороги, и там происходили отчаянные бор...бои. Шестер был сам в Вергове. [Нерзборчиво], наш адвокат. Он был в Вергове...
David Boder: Кто?
Fira Monk: Шестер, Яков Михайлович.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Он пошёл на Верков и предложил свои услуги...
David Boder: Это какой город?
Fira Monk: Вер-ков.
David Boder: Вергов.
Fira Monk: Да.
David Boder: [In German] Was ist das?
Fira Monk: [In Russian] Это город [технические помехи]. И там были очень большие бои. И Шестер туда пошёл со своей женой, его сын был в армии Резистанс, в маки. И Шестер предложил свои услуги. Я помню, что в 1904? году он был полковником армии. И вот ему сказали [неразборчиво]: «Милый друг, мы Вам очень благодарны за то, что Вы предлагаете свои услуги, но пушки, которыми Вы стреляли во время той войны, уже давно заржавели. У нас совершенно другие орудия». И он тоже совершил бесшумную доставку, благодаря тому, что он не был евреем, и его жена христианка. И благодаря ещё тому, что их арестовали не [неразборчиво, очень тихо]. Их держали в течение двух часов с поднятыми руками наверх, чтоб они сказали, что они евреи. Конечно, они стали всё отрицать, и тогда их отпустили. И тогда Шестер спустился вниз, с этой горы и попал к нам в Вуарон, мы его не узнали—он постарел на 10 лет. [Пауза] Ну, значит, всё время мы работали. Всё было чинно, мирно. Все наши отделения работали на юге Франции, наши фирмы. У нас даже шёл разговор о том, что ОРТ сделает недоделанную работу на 7 лет. Мы делали фальшивые бумаги, мы прятали детей, и делали всё, что нужно было. И 8 сентября 43-го года я приезжаю в Гренобль и вижу, вдруг эти бедные итальянцы ведутся стадом—мы ещё ничего не знали,—ведутся стадом под руководством каких-то молодых немцев. Я спросила у первого встречного, в чём дело. Он сказал: «Мадам, Вы что, не знаете? Вчера было объявлено перемирие между Германией и Италией. И вот наши [неразборчиво]». И тогда я поняла, что...
David Boder: Эти колонны гнали [неразборчиво]
Fira Monk: Это оккупационные власти.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Fira Monk: Нет! Это оккупационные власти. Они совершенно...
David Boder: Это итальянцы, которые составляли оккупационные власти и которые...
Fira Monk: Да.
David Boder: . . . к вам хорошо относились.
Fira Monk: Идеально. Они вообще нас не видели. Они на нас не обращали внимания, это были самые лучшие года.
David Boder: Так. И вот их, значит, арестовывали...
Fira Monk: И их арестовывали, они ходили без поясов и этих шляп с пёрышками, ходили в довольно таком растрёпанном виде по городу, и немцы сейчас же их забирали. Первое, что они сделали—это они сделали облавы. И когда вечером я спросила...
David Boder: Облавы на кого?
Fira Monk: На всех: на евреев, на резистанцев, французов—кто попадался в руки. Когда я приехала в школу, я спрашиваю моих учениц, я им говорю: «Господа, что делать? Хотите ли вы продолжать работать или нет?» Они говорят: «Да, будьте спокойны, мы хотим продолжать». И мы работали так до 12 сентября. 12 сентября—это было уже немножко рискованно, потому что облавы были...
David Boder: Это какого года?
Fira Monk: 43-го года.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Облавы были за облавами. И было просто рискованно ехать. Я лично три раза не могла [неразборчиво], потому что я боюсь.
Fira Monk: В первый раз я им проплакала песню о том, что у меня грудной ребёнок лежит в Вуароне, и если я не приеду, то он умрёт с голоду. Во второй раз я вообще так промелькнула тёмной птичкой, а в третий раз я подошла к французу и сказала: «Слушай, если ты меня не пропустишь, так знай, что я погибну». Вообщем, я доверялась своему французскому духу. Он на меня посмотрел, очевидно, понял, что тут...неспроста я его так прошу. Он мне говорит: «Подойдите к третьему от меня налево и потом поверните направо». Я так и сделала. И я приехала домой.
David Boder: Третьему кто?
Fira Monk: Третьему городовому.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: И третьему городовому я сказала просто: «[неразборчиво]». И он на меня посмотрел [говорит по-французски]. И я проскочила. Но, конечно, это всё были чудеса.
David Boder: Переведите это на русский язык.
Fira Monk: [Неразборчиво] я, значит, сказала: «Пропустите меня», а он говорит: «Я Вас не вижу».
David Boder: Ага.
Fira Monk: Я пошла. Ну, а потом уже, значит, уже было плохо, и всё-таки через Вуарон только проезжали немецкие автомобили Вермахта с немецкими солдатами, и вся наша полиция была разоружена. Но всё-таки...эээ...в начале жандармерия...
David Boder: Т.е. она была [неразборчиво]
Fira Monk: [неразборчиво], да. Они все проводили подпольную работу. В нашем Вуаронском комиссариате делались фальшивые карточки. С официальной подписью комиссара. Комиссар был тогда...был учеником медицинского факультета. [Пауза] Ну, что ещё? Есть очень много сказать [неразборчиво] невозможно. А потом, значит, в феврале началось такое довольно неприятное явление. Милиция обосновалась в Вуароне, и, причём, она, конечно, выбрала своим местом жительства отель, лежащий совсем недалеко, в 10 минутах ходьбы, от отеля, в котором помещался ОРТ. Тогда мы решили, что тут дело швах—это неважно, и такое соседство для нас совсем не было приятно. И мы официально закрыли контору на...эээ...на долгосрочный отпуск. А ещё до того, с февраля 43-го года мы не имели вообще право...нет, с февраля—это уже был 44-ый, с февраля 44-го,—а с февраля 43-го года иностранные евреи не имели права работать в...эээ...еврейских организациях, мы были [неразборчиво]. И тут я должна отметить, что ОРТ был единственной организацией—[неразборчиво], но я говорю всегда то, что есть,—был единственной организацией, которая платила жалование всех своих служащих, всех своих сотрудников, даже если они уезжали прятаться, он им делал фальшивые бумаги, т.е. нужно было [неразборчиво] фальшивыми бумагами. Он платил за все передвижения ОРТовцев, он был как родной отец по отношению к [неразборчиво]. Поэтому у нас такое совершенно иное отношение к нашей организации—мы её любим, как часть...как часть самого себя. Это была, конечно, идея Френкеля, потому что если бы не было Френкеля, не было бы ОРТа. [Неразборчиво, очень тихо]
David Boder: А как ОРТ получал свои деньги?
Fira Monk: Как он получал, об этом лучше не говорить. Приходили какие-то молодые люди: «Вы Мадам Монк?» «Да». «Вот» -давали мне в руки какой-то пакет, завёрнутый несколькими слоями бумаги. Я брала этот пакет, шла к Френкелю, говорю: «Вот, я получила». «Сколько?» Я говорю: «Я понятия не имею. Не смотрела». [неразборчиво]. Мы через разных послов, через разных молодых людей Резистанс посылали Ростиславскому? почту, чтобы он имел понятие о том, что с нами происходит, но это длилось недолго. Был...наступил момент, когда мы боялись, что мы вообще будем отрезаны, будем сидеть без денег и без ничего. И...но нам очень помогали, и были люди, которые нам давали деньги. Я эти финансовые вещи не знаю, это меня никогда не интересовало, меня интересовало только так, что деньги есть, и что есть...эээ...что послать тем, которые от нас ушли, потому что они боялись. Особенно боялись мужчины, потому что они были первые в большой опасности. [Пауза] Например, когда это было? Уже было в 44-ом году в феврале, да. Нам пришли и сказали, что нужно спрятаться. Мы не имели, куда пойти. Тогда к нам пришла одна барышня из Резистанса: «Давайте я вас поведу». Завела нас в одну рабочую французскую семью. Они нас приняли с распростёртыми объятьями. Это было поздно вечером, приблизительно к 12 часам. Эта дама выводила собаку. [Неразборчиво]
David Boder: Это была собака, которая...
Fira Monk: А! Райт....которую мы назвали Райтом в честь англичан [неразборчиво], если не ошибаюсь. Фамилия у него такая. И вот значит, мы втроём с [неразборчиво] прибыли к этим совершенно чужим людям, которые уступили нам свою...эээ...спальню, которые не знали, как нас приласкать. Мы у них пробыли две недели. Потом нам товарищ сказал, что можно идти домой. И вот когда я прихожу домой, я вижу дома приглашение из комиссариата. Прихожу в комиссариат, я думала, что это [неразборчиво] что-то такое [неразборчиво]. И мне заявляют: «О Боже мой, о Боже мой, какой ужас! Мадам, Вы должны поехать в Германию». Всё дело...оказывается, они меня приняли за мужчину, немцы, и я должна была ехать на принудительные работы в качестве мужчины.
David Boder: Т.е. как? По карточке? По...эээ...айдентити...
Fira Monk: Нет. Там была...они собирали тогда мужчин на принудительные работы, без различия вероисповедания или расовой, без различия рас. И все мужчины получили, конечно, все удрали, кто куда мог. Только я получила это приглашение. И я сказала, что я не пойду. И в комиссариате три городовых ко мне подошли и сказали: «Мадам, Вы имеете, где спрятаться? Потому что, если не имеете, мы сами Вас поведём на ферму, на которой Вы можете оставаться жить до конца войны, которая надеемся скоро окончиться и Вас [неразборчиво]» Но так как я имела одну семью друзей, я просидела у них ещё несколько дней. Тем временем одна француженка поехала в Гренобль и узнала все новшества, доказала, что я женщина, а не мужчина, и это не имело никаких последствий. [Пауза] Ну, а потом, значит, у нас была милиция...
David Boder: Так это просто выяснить: немцы составляли списки по каким-то карточкам...
Fira Monk: Немцы...
David Boder: . . . и записали Вас как-будто мужчина...
Fira Monk: Да.
David Boder: Ну, да.
Fira Monk: Ну, а потом там была, как я Вам говорила, приехала милиция, учредилась недалеко от ОРТа. И они следили за нами [неразборчиво] которую можно себе представить. Недалеко от Вуарона, в 2,5км, находился детский дом под руководством раввина Шмиерсона.
David Boder: Детский?
Fira Monk: Детский. Это ритуальный детский дом.
David Boder: Ортодоксальный?
Fira Monk: Ортодоксальный, да. Там, конечно, детей всех прятали, и раввин там спрятался. И дом...
David Boder: Шмиерсон был, что, хасидский еврей?
Fira Monk: Хасидский, да. Из Киева.
David Boder: Из Киева?
Fira Monk: Да. Там его имя, кажется,...
David Boder: -Так. [Неразборчиво]
Fira Monk: Нет, он из Киева, с рыжей бородой.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Он очень многое сделал. Когда ушли итальянцы, он, думая спасти евреев от немцев, повёз очень большое количество за собственный счёт в Ниццу.
David Boder: Он что, был, французским раввином?
Fira Monk: Нет, он русский.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Он русский. Он имеет тут свою иешиву, школу.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво, очень тихо]
Fira Monk: И значит он...
David Boder: А где школа?
Fira Monk: На 10 Рю [неразборчиво]. Это возле [неразборчиво, очень тихо].
David Boder: [Неразборчиво, очень тихо]
Fira Monk: Ну, вообщем, раввин Шмиерсон повёз в Ниццу большое количество евреев из Вуарона и окрестностей. К сожалению, ему операция не удалась. Он думал сделать хорошо, но немцы его опередили. И когда он приехал в Ниццу, немцы там уже были. И он там сидел четыре дня взаперти, не выходя на свет Божий...[Пауза]
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 111 [not clear, very soft, recording stops abruptly]
David Boder: This is Spool 112. The interviewee is Ms. Fira Monk...ah...a executive secretary at the [unintelligible] ORT organization in France. Paris, September the 7th, 1946. Illinois Institute of Technology, Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.
David Boder: [In Russian] Мадам Монк, Вы, значит, нам говорили, про раввина Шмиерсона, который повёз детей в Ниццу, но был опереден...эээ...опереждён немцами.
Fira Monk: Он повёз не только детей, он вёз с собой очень много взрослых, потому что в Вуароне с начала войны оказалось 195 еврейских семей.
David Boder: Ну, что значит «он увёз с собой»? Что это...? Что это за такое...эээ...мероприятие было?
Fira Monk: Что это...? Да. Он нанял несколько камеланов [неразборчиво] и разослал своих людей ко всем живущим в Вуароне евреям, и в окрестностях...
David Boder: Виерон?
Fira Monk: Вуарон. [Говорит по буквам] V-о-i-r-о-n....и сказал: «Господа, я считаю, что самое лучшее для нас всех уехать от немцев и поехать в Ниццу. Из Ниццы у нас будет больше возможности перебраться в Италию, или же итальянцы останутся в Ницце—будет итальянская, наверное, власть». И тогда многие поехали. Я знаю, потому что моя бабушка тогда ещё жила в Ницце. У меня не было ехать никакого желания. Я всегда говорила: «Там, где массовое бегство—оттуда беги сама». И это будет самая удобная вещь немцам прийти туда и наложить [неразборчиво] на всех, как кошка на мышь.
David Boder: Давайте поправим: «там, куда массовое бегство...»
Fira Monk: «Там, куда массовое бегство».
David Boder: Так. А «оттуда беги сама»?
Fira Monk: А «оттуда беги сама». [Пауза] Там хорошо, где нас нет—это старая история. Ну, вот, он, значит, начал собирать со всех сторон людей, и ему действительно удалось с очень многими вернуться обратно. Но, к большому сожалению, большая часть погибла.
David Boder: То есть?
Fira Monk: В Ницце на вокзале стояли немцы, которые ловили людей, просто говоря, сетками как в больших городах ловят собак; их сажали тут же сейчас же в скотские вагоны, перевозили в Дранси и после того, как они пребывали в Дранси, их перевозили в Аушвитц и так далее.
David Boder: Где Дранси?
Fira Monk: Дранси недалеко от Парижа. На севере Парижа.
David Boder: Это что? Военное какое-то поселение?
Fira Monk: Нет!
David Boder: Или казармы?
Fira Monk: Нет, это маленький городочек, предместье. Это обычное предместье, там были казармы. И они в этих казармах предместья устроили некий раз...разборочный лагерь.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Я недавно проезжала мимо Дранси, но у меня просто не хватило силы сойти и осмотреть этот город, потому что я считаю этот город местом смерти всех людей которые оттуда ушли.
Fira Monk: И значит, когда Шмиерсон вернулся—за ним поехала одна знакомая француженка, она его привезла на такси из Ниццы,—и раввина сейчас же спрятали. Его поместили в...эээ...одном...
David Boder: Французская еврейка?
Fira Monk: Нет, христианка поехала, христианка.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Очень милая женщина. Её муж погиб потом, его немцы застрелили. Мать двух детей. И, значит, раввина спрятали в одном заброшенном доме в городе. Это было в 5км от Гренобля, и его жена [неразборчиво] остаётся, вышла один раз из дома, чтобы пойти куда-то за вещами, к ней подошло двое. Её арестовали. Тогда же арестовали ещё нескольких людей, и [неразборчиво] покойного брата нашего агронома. Их повезли в...в полутора километрах от Вуарона на горку, где они...милиция реквизировала частную виллу, и там трёх-четырёх людей подвергли самым страшным пыткам и издеваниям. Раввишна Шмиерсон должна была есть все их испражнения, которые они делали на том, толчённые граммофонные пластинки, пить мыльную и соляную воду. А один господин, некий Херцог, был подстрелен прямо на улице. Они говорили потом, что он защищался. И его избили до того, что человек через некоторое время скончался.
David Boder: Чего они хотели?
Fira Monk: Они хотели денег! У раввишны они хотели узнать, где раввин Шмиерсон. Они его считали очень опасным элементом.
David Boder: Это кто были—французы или немцы?
Fira Monk: А это были французы! Это была милиция французская.
David Boder: Ну, да.
Fira Monk: Подонки общества. Вообще, в милицию брали людей из тюрем. Им говорили, что: «Мы тебя освободим. Ты должен к нам поступить». Других брали тем, что им давали сколько-то тысяч франков. В самом начале, когда была организована милиция, в неё пошло очень много бывших военных [говорит по-французски] -участники старой войны. Они думали, что милиция—это объединение военных. Но когда они увидели, честные ушли, а всякого...
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Fira Monk: Ну, да, а подонки общества остались. Тем более, что за голову каждого еврея давали 3 тысячи франков. Тогда это была очень приличная сумма. Ну, да, 3 тысячи франков...
David Boder: Как это—за голову?
Fira Monk: За голову евреев платили 3 тыщи франков.
David Boder: Еврея, которого немцы искали?
Fira Monk: Нет, зачем искать?! Просто говорили, что здесь живёт еврей. Они ходили и говорили: «Здесь живёт еврей. Идите его арестовать». И когда, значит, они доносили, его арестовывают, этому человеку выдавали 3 тысячи франков. Но мы же говорили, что милиция, очевидно, ценит нас гораздо дороже. Христа продали за 30 серебряников, а нас за 3 тысячи.
David Boder: А франки же не были серебряными?
Fira Monk: Это неважно. Они считались по золотой валюте.
David Boder: Кто?
Fira Monk: [Неразборчиво] золотые лавки. Ну, потом префект из Гренобля...
David Boder: Всё подорожало?
Fira Monk: Да, но жизнь человеческая подешевела.
David Boder: Так вот, если там за 30, а тут за 3 тысячи?! Цена поднялась.
Fira Monk: И, очевидно, цена жизни всё-таки поднялась. Понимаете, столько времени прошло. И вот тогда, когда были арестованы наши друзья, раввин...эээ...префект города Гренобля сам [неразборчиво] в чём здесь дело. «Кто здесь хозяин—я или они?» И говорит этой милиции: «Слушайте, или вы выпустите этих евреев, либо вы здесь остаётесь, либо я остаюсь». Написал об этом в Виши. Не знаю, что там произошло. Это всё покрыто большой мистерией, каким-то тёмным занавесом. Во всяком случае, раввиншу Шмиерсон, Вика? выпустили, а бедный Херцог скончался там. Его отвезли, и он уже умер. И раввиншу выпустили. Тогда их перевели...перевели в другое место, в 10 километрах от самого Вуерона, где они жили на ферме. Всё окружение не знали, они не знали, я не знала. Во всяком случае, когда я к нему пришла, я никого новых не встретила. Я к нему очень часто ходила. Он оставался без денег, и ему тогда передавалась...
David Boder: Раввин?
Fira Monk: Сергей Александрович. Своих детей, которые были у него на попечении, он спрятал. И в один прекрасный день милиция узнала, что там [неразборчиво] семья Резистанс. Они взяли с собой двух или трёх немцев гестапо и пошли туда. Когда они увидели плачущих детей, тогда немцы сказали: «В чём дело? Ведь нам сказали, что это Резистанс, а тут только [неразборчиво]» Это им не помешало забрать всех 19 детей, начиная с 3-летнего возраста до 19 лет.
David Boder: А сколько детей там было?
Fira Monk: 22.
David Boder: А что они сделали...?
Fira Monk: Они [неразборчиво, помехи]. Все 22 ребёнка были забраны.
David Boder: Вы сказали 19.
Fira Monk: Нет. От 3 до 19 лет.
David Boder: О!
Fira Monk: От 3 до 19 лет. И только одному удалось бежать. Он бежал из Дранси. Это брат моей одной приятельницы. Он попал [неразборчиво] в Дранси, когда он работал на рельсах, обезвреживая бомбу, которая будто бы не взорвалась. Немец ушёл, в ту сторону. Тогда он и, не ожидая его возвращения, удрал. И через три недели он появился в Вуароне. Потом его отправили...общими усилиями его отправили к испанской границе. Он перешёл в Испанию, и был отправлен в Палестину. И остался там. А остальные погибли. Из них вот вернулся только один молодой человек 19 лет. [Пауза] Ну, а раввин сам скрывался, всё время. И потом, позже немножко, я как-то от него возвращалась, и меня встречают мои две приятельницы и говорят мне: «Слушай, какой ужас! Какой кошмар! Шмиерсона убили». Я сначала не решилась сказать, что я от него, потому что всё держалось в большом секрете, даже от самых близких друзей. Тем более, что в тот день я ему отнесла крупную сумму денег. У него ещё были люди, набожные евреи, которые скрывались сами в Резистанс, которые сидели без копейки денег, и которых он содержал. Так я сказала: «В чём дело? Вы мне говорите, как?» В [неразборчиво, название места по-французски]—это 6км от Вуарона, убили Шмиерсона. Вы знаете, они начали плакать. Я говорю: «Послушайте, девочки. Шмиерсона не убили, я от него только что. Когда его убили?». «Полтора часа тому назад» «[неразборчиво] тоже полтора часа, это всё-таки невозможные вещи. Если бы они уже были там, значит, они меня б тоже поймали. И я бы не сидела сейчас за чайным столом». Оказалась тогда следующая история: что они приехали [неразборчиво], и спросили девочку одну: «Скажи, ты не знаешь здесь одного господина с бородой?» И девочка действительно сказала: «Да как же! Конечно! Вот он живёт в этом маленьком домике». И они зашли, милиционеры, туда. Это был маленький домик, в котором жило двое евреев. Они устроили, правда, фальшивую стену, за которой было нарыто углубление, в котором могло поместиться два человека. Зять этого господина туда спрятался и сказал: «Идёмте со мной, папа». Отец сказал: «Нет. Если мне суждено жить, я буду жить, если же нет—сын»,—говорит,—«я Божий». И они зашли. И они взяли этих евреев. Двух. Там пришёл второй с ним обсу...немножко поговорить на религиозные темы, а может быть, на политические. И через три часа нашли [неразборчиво].
David Boder: [Неразборчиво] и они его приняли за Шмиерсона?
Fira Monk: Они его приняли за Шмиерсона. Они потом себе кусали локти, что это не был раввин, но они всё-таки были очень довольны, что увели с собой двух евреев. Ну, а в апреле 44-го года, когда...
David Boder: Это была милиция?
Fira Monk: Это была милиция...милиция. А в апреле 44-го года, когда милиция была [неразборчиво] в нашем Вуароне, там был шеф её, господин Жордаль. Когда мы приехали в Вуарон, он издавал маленькую газету «Вуаронский листок» [неразборчиво] грязная газета. Она очень [неразборчиво] писала. «Кто эти люди, которые ходят вверх по горке?» Наш дом тогда находился на горе. «...вверх по горке в непромокаемых пальто с портфелями под мышкой. Врачи ли это? Нет. Адвокаты? О, нет! Военные? Боже сохрани! Это иудеи, простите. [неразборчиво]» Это они писали: «Мы счастливы сообщить вам, что господин Френкель со своей супругой переехал в Аушвитц. Мы счастливы сообщить Вуаронскому населению, что госпожа Монк со своей матерью переехали из отеля в собственную квартиру». Наша квартира была какая-то полуразвалившаяся халтура [неразборчиво]. «Господин Леви?! Ну, конечно, господин Леви живёт в замке». Жил он в замке? Нет. Потому что это был замок...потому что была очень дешёвая...ему знакомые уступили комнату в одном так называемом замке. Это был очень большой дом, стоящий посередине сада. И вот. Значит, редактор этой газеты, господин Жордаль, принимал участие в аресте и ограблении всех евреев, которых только могли поймать в окрестностях Гренобля, и который принимал участие в аресте раввинши Шмиерсон. И в один прекрасный день...его дом находился напротив большой профессиональной государственной школы. Мальчики из этой профессиональной школы были, конечно, в Резистанс. И вот в один прекрасный день утром, в семь часов утра я выхожу в город, и мне одна женщина говорит: «Как, мадам? Вы в городе?! Вы знаете, что Жордаля убили?» Мне стало неприятно. Она говорит: «Да, его убили. Я Вас прошу, будьте осторожны, потому что может быть большое несчастье». Я пошла домой. И в это время было очень тяжёлое время во Франции. У нас не было хлеба совершенно. А так как у меня всё-таки маленькая семья, которую нужно кормить, я решила, будь, что будет, но хлеб нужно достать. И я пошла в город. Встречаю знакомого городового: «Куда Вы идёте?» Я говорю: «Я иду за папиросами и за хлебом, потому что [неразборчиво]». Он говорит: «Идите, но я Вас прошу, сделайте это скоро, потому что я не знаю, что это будет».
David Boder: [Неразборчиво, очень тихо]
Fira Monk: Городовой. Простой городовой.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: И я пошла в магазин, где я покупала на чёрном рынке папиросы. [Пауза] И вошла в магазин. Это не...эээ...хлебный мага...не хлебная лавка, а вообще универсальный магазин, и думала, может быть, я найду сухари. Я спрашиваю кассиршу. Она говорит: «Нет, сухарей больше нет». Тогда я уже хотела взяться за...эээ...дверную ручку, чтобы уйти. Ко мне подошёл какой-то тип, очень большой, очень красивый, вооружённый до зубов и сказал мне по-французски—это довольно некорректно звучит: «Идите к чёрту! Вы нам здесь всем намозолили глаза!» Ну, я решила сначала обидеться. Всё было дело секунды, решение было, конечно, такое, сразу пойти чуть ли не в бой, но потом я решила, нет, дама не дерётся, и кроме того, у него пулемёт, и я ушла. И когда я встретила на улице несколько знакомых евреев, я им сказала: «Господа, идите домой. Сегодня что-то очень плохо пахнет». К сожалению, не все меня послушали. Я пришла домой. И я узнала через час, что на площади было взято семь евреев, и они были уведены. Это было в 2 часа дня. В 6 часов вечера ко мне пришёл один молодой человек из Резистанс и сказал: «Мадам, семь человек убито за мельницей». Они убиты самым жутким образом. У них вырваны глаза. Им вырвали ногти. Им вырывали каждый волос отдельно. Им срезали члены и всё [неразборчиво, помехи]. Они издевались над ними самым гнуснейшим образом. Плакать не было времени. Мы подошли в комиссариат, и мы попросили в комиссариате, чтобы послали на место одного из тех, с фотографическим аппаратом. В восемь часов вечера фотографии с полным отчётом были отосланы в Швейцарию молодыми людьми, которые...
David Boder: Это как? Из полиции?!
Fira Monk: Из полиции.
David Boder: Это что? Французская полиция?
Fira Monk: Французская полиция делала фотографии. Нам отдали то, что нужно было. Это ведь были полицейские...
David Boder: Полиция была в Резистанс?
David Boder: Она, конечно, была связана с Резистанс.
Fira Monk: Так.
David Boder: И они не имели право [неразборчиво]?
Fira Monk: Они не могли. Секретарь комиссариата был депортирован. И все, кто был в национальной полиции, при нашем комиссариате был депортирован. У нас очень много христиан взяли. У нас было два налёта гестапо, они на евреев тогда не обращали внимания, а брали только христиан. [Пауза] И вот, среди них...я увидела сама эти фотографии. Среди них был один молодой господин 36 лет, отец троих детей. Жена его ждала четвёртого ребёнка. Когда мне принесли фотографии—я видела их [неразборчиво, помехи], я спросила их: «Кто этот старик?» «Как? Ведь это [фамилия неразборчиво]» Я говорю: «Т.е. как [фамилия неразборчиво]?!» Я видела пред собой старика 70 лет. Это было действительно ужасно. И вот в 8 часов вечера все эти документы пошли в Швейцарию. Этот отчёт был прочитано радио [непонятно, по-французски], потому что у нас тогда было радио, которое передавало тоже.
David Boder: Эээ...подпольное радио?
Fira Monk: Конечно, подпольное. Его наладил один поляк. И на следующий день английское радио прочло всему миру о том, что произошло в Вуароне. [Пауза] Это была месть милиции за...за то, что убили Жордаля со всей его семьей, включая трёхлетнего ребёнка. Но мы знали, что это не была работа Резистанс. Потому что Резистанс не убивала маленьких детей. Притом знали. Это нам сказали люди знающие. И потом это оказалось правдой, что это было просто сведением счётов. Они награбили 26 миллионов франков.
David Boder: Кто?
Fira Monk: Милиция.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: И они хотели делиться. И, конечно, каждый из них хотел самый больший кусок. Жордаль вообще был господин прекрасного дома. Он была обладателем нескольких домов в [неразборчиво]. Официально он имел эти [говорит по-французски], знаете, [неразборчиво]...
Fira Monk: . . . ну, центральное отопление.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: А в действительности он заведовал домами терпимости, так что прекрасное семейство. И вся семья была убита, остался только один его сын. Что с ним стало, не знаю. Все остальные участники этого гнусного убийства были убиты Резистанс. Некоторые [неразборчиво], некоторые после. Потом ещё в 5км от Вуарона было очень...такой показательный случай. Там был один поляк-крестьянин. Он всегда был очень весёлый парень, работал в каменоломнях, и был рыбак. И это был прекрасный день [неразборчиво]...
David Boder: Где работал?
Fira Monk: Ну, в каменоломнях.
David Boder: И?
Fira Monk: Ну, это был рубаха-парень. Весёлый, любил выпить, отец семи детей и вообще человек, ему всё было по колено. И вот то, что я Вам расскажу, видела моя подруга своими глазами из окна своей гостиницы. Она жила как крестьянка в этой деревне, была певицей, называется [говорит название театра по-французски]. Приехал автомобиль, в котором сидело два гестапо и два милиционера. И подошли к поляку, сидевшему вместе с другими поляками у стола за стаканом пива. И попросили их раздеться. Значит, сначала все поразились. Говорят: «Вы евреи?» «Нет». «Тогда разденьтесь». Тогда они разделись, доказали, что они не евреи, и поляк был немножечко подвыпивши. И он поднял на гестапо руку! Ах! «Гуд бай, гуд бай!» Тот, во-первых, увидел польскую руку: «Как это! Поляк поднял руку! И ещё «гуд бай». Он схватил этого поляка за шиворот, всадил его в автомобиль и увезли. Три дня позже нашли его труп. Правда, городок оказался на высоте. Его жена [неразборчиво], но, конечно, его не вернёшь. Что самый это несчастный парень был. Город пошёл ей изумительно навстречу. Она сейчас же получила 20 тысяч франков. Когда она рожала своего четвёртого ребёнка, она была помещена в городскую больницу—больница там изумительная, между прочим,—и начальник её, доктор Бова [имя неразборчиво], был на большой высоте. Он тоже лечил резистанцев, делал операции, и всё. У неё, конечно, денег не взяли. Она получила замечательнейшее приданое для ребёнка. Я заикнулась о том, что мне нужно пару распашонок, мне одна дама-француженка, она работает тоже в Резистанс, принесла картон вещей, которые за самые большие деньги вообще нельзя было получить, потому что, Вы знаете, как у нас всё было ограничено, и дети получали 3 кило шерсти на три первых года жизни, в то время как на ребёнка нужно 5 кило [неразборчиво]. Ей обеспечили определённую пенсию со стороны еврейских организаций, со стороны Резистанс. Но всё-таки это не вернёт её мужа, тем более, что они очень дружно жили. Ну, и вот как раз в это время, когда милиция царствовала и властвовала, приехала в Вуарон моя бабушка с французскими бумагами. Моя бабушка кроме «Оревуар, бонжур, месье, мадам» ничего не могла сказать. Она приехала как мадам Вуараль, глухонемая эльзаска. Её принимали...
David Boder: Как глухонемая?
Fira Monk: Да, я думаю. Она ж не могла говорить! [говорит со смехом]
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Fira Monk: Нет, она очень...всё время в дороге она очень быстро разговаривала по-русски. Она вообще была того мнения, что: «Ничего, я проеду».
David Boder: [Неразборчиво], что она глухонемая?
Fira Monk: Да, по бумагам было написано, что...эээ...как называется...[говорит по-французски]—это глухонемая, всю жизнь. Привезла её невестка матери,...эээ...вдова маминого брата, которая приехала...Когда она говорит по-французски, Вы на 8 километров услышите, что она русская. И она делает ошибки в каждом втором слове, и всё-таки она приехала как мадмуазель Вуараль и была уверена, что никто не знает, что она русская. И вот в один прекрасный день у нас обыск дома. Приходит тип из Виши. У нас обычно было их довольно много, было общественно всё время. Но это был самый неприятный, потому что из Виши приехал тип и делал обыски во всех еврейских домах. Он делал обыск в доме [неразборчиво]—это наш старый сотрудник, который работал 25 лет в ОРТе, он теперь в Америке. У него он стучал по стенкам и непременно хотел доказать ему о том, что он советский гражданин, что он советский шпион и Бог его знает что, но всё-таки ничего...сумяшившись, должен был уйти, потому что не было что взять. Он прибежал к нам, и моя тётушка здесь стоит со своими фальшивыми бумагами. И он её спрашивает: «Вы давно в Вуароне?» Моя тётя сиплым от страха голосом заявляет: «Уви». Тогда я говорю: «Вы знаете, она очень простужена. Так что я предпочитаю даже, чтобы она не говорила».
David Boder: Это та, что должна была быть глухонемой?
Fira Monk: Нет, бабушка была глухонемой. А это её невестка.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Глухонемая бабушка—мы сейчас же перевели её на настоящие бумаги. Я пошла в комиссариат, сказала: «Так и так, приехала моя бабушка». Нужно ей сделать бумаги, потому что она приехала [неразборчиво]. Всё. Мне сейчас же выдали на неё ресиписе [неразборчиво]. Она даже ни разу не заходила в комиссариат. А невестка, значит, решила остаться под своими бумагами. Когда её спросили: «Давно ли Вы в Вуароне?», она ответила «Уви». И по её [неразборчиво] сразу можно было узнать это...что она не родилась во...под Парижем. Вот, я сказала, что она простужена, и что у неё хриплый голос. Ну, я не знаю, понял ли он, хотел или не хотел, но, во всяком случае, он на неё больше не обращал внимания, а набросился на мою библиотеку. В моей библиотеке очень много английских книг. Он спросил: «Ага! У Вас столько английских книг! Почему?» Я говорю: «Очень просто. Я надеюсь, что англичане здесь скоро будут. [Неразборчиво, очень тихо]» Он побледнел, но ничего не ответил. Потом он начал рыться у меня в...эээ...чемодане и вытащил пару...
David Boder: А Вы действительно так ответили?
Fira Monk: Я решила, всё равно, если умереть, то хотя бы с музыкой. Я не хотела их бояться. Я ненавидела...я знала, что чем я буду нахальней, тем он будет скромнее, потому что они всё-таки идиоты. Они ведь не знали...это были совершенно некультурные люди. Они терялись, если вы им говорили что-то такое, которое не входило в их понятия. Они знали, вот это и это мы должны сделать. А что будет дальше, они уже не понимали. И дать какой-нибудь более достойный ответ они уже не могли. [Пауза] И когда он начал копаться в моём чемодане, вытащил пару моих трико. [Неразборчиво] Я говорю: «Слушайте, не нужно копаться в чужих вещах. Нужно извиняться». «Да, да, Вы знаете, я должен исполнять поручение, которое мне свыше даны». Я говорю: «Простите, если мне [неразборчиво] скажут, сделайте то-то и то-то, я буду против этого, я просто скажу: «Господа, я этого не хочу делать». Но [неразборчиво] я не стану копаться в чужих чемоданах». Тогда он с сердцем хлопнул крышкой чемодана, сказав: «С Вами вообще нельзя справиться!»
David Boder: Это немец?
Fira Monk: Француз, француз! Немцы у меня ни разу не были. Я прошла...т.е. все прошли сквозь эту оккупацию, как набожный раввин между каплями дождя. Вы знаете этот анекдот?
David Boder: Про раввина?
Fira Monk: Про раввина. А раввин был посередине. Направо было гестапо, налево была милиция, а мы были посерёдке.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Ну, и потом всё это пошло очень быстрым темпом. Как мы узнали, 6 мая...6 июня была высадка. У нас сразу немножко поднялась...
David Boder: В 45-ом году?
Fira Monk: В 44-ом!
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Fira Monk: Всех. Нам стало легче дышать. Каждый раз прибегал кто-то из Резистанс: «Ах, они будут завтра наступать. Ах, они будут завтра там-то». Мы не отходили от радио. Слушали радио до 2-3 часов ночи. Мы ложились спать...
David Boder: Какое радио вы слушали?
Fira Monk: Конечно, английское. [Неразборчиво]
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Все говорят по-французски. Все спрашивали разрешения. Ведь был такой анекдот. Значит, одна женщина пришла в церковь молиться за...ммм...молиться за благополучие своего мужа, немецкого военнопленного. И она говорит,...ммм...что сначала хотела бы пойти исповедоваться. Священник ей говорит: «Когда ж ты хочешь прийти?» Она говорит: «Я бы хотела прийти в 11 часов вечера». А он говорит: « В 11 часов вечера я не могу». «Почему?» «Я сижу дома, я слушаю английское радио». Т.е. слушать английское радио было гораздо важнее. Это было очень хорошее радио «Атлантик». Они давали эту...эээ...танцевальную музыку и между прочим давали новости. Это были самые лучшие известия.
David Boder: Это [неразборчиво]?
Fira Monk: Это было тоже подпольное радио. Потом мы слушали французское радио тоже. Мы слушали немецкое радио! Мы слушали речи Гитлера и Гёббельса. Это было страшно [неразборчиво], когда мы слышали: «Мы не отдадим этого, мы не отдадим того!» Мы ведь знали, что это было уже давно взято. Немцы этого не знали или [неразборчиво]. Когда они кричали о том, что «мы не отдадим Сталинград», тогда мы уже пили водку за взятие Сталинграда. Мы запомнили [неразборчиво], потому что нельзя...
David Boder: Вы пили водку за...эээ...
Fira Monk: . . . за взятие нашими! За победу! За [неразборчиво] конечно.
David Boder: Да.
Fira Monk: [Пауза] Ну, вот, и тогда стало всё светлее и светлее дышать. Милиция уже как-то смущалась. Резистанс сходила с гор и была у нас...вообще стала хозяином. Они разъезжали на автомобилях, они были вооружены до зубов. Это была всё молодёжь. [Неразборчиво]
David Boder: Так война ещё не кончилась?
Fira Monk: Нет! Война ещё не кончилась. Ещё не было освобождения. Это только шла борьба за Францию. И вот 15 августа 44-го года к нам прибегает один мальчик, из маки, с оторванными пуговицами. Мы садимся ему пришивать пуговицы. Он говорит: «Господа, 19-го Гренобль будет взят нашими!» Так я его и спрашиваю: «Вы столько раз обещали «19», что надоело». 19 мы не были освобождены, но 22 августа приходит к нам один знакомый. Мы его не узнали, очень был пожилой. Мы перед нами видим молодого человека, с распахнутым воротником, который берёт меня за руку и: «Идёмте на площадь! Вы слышите колокола?» Я не слышала. Я услышала, когда [неразборчиво] через окно. И мы вышли на площадь, вернее не вышли—мы побежали. Площадь перед церковью—готическая церковь XII столетия—была запружена народом. Это было...
David Boder: В 44-ом году?
Fira Monk: В 44-ом году. 22 августа. Была масса народа. Все плакали, все целовали друг друга. На меня напали какие-то люди, и меня начали целовать. Я их в жизни не видела. Я только потом узнала, кто это был. Какой-то храбрец влез на колокольню с трёхцветным флагом. И когда этот трёхцветный флаг начал биться в воздухе, и когда французы стали на колени и стали петь «Марсельезу», тогда я поняла, что [неразборчиво] Франции, что все эти ужасы [неразборчиво] этого старого маленького города. Это было изумительно красиво. И, во-первых, ещё очень интересный момент. Было серенькое утро, и когда шла милиция—это не литература—небо стало синее и засияло солнце. [Пауза] Это было до того красиво! И через два часа появились первые американские танки. Появились эти мальчики в этих мохнатых шлемах, из которых ещё торчали всякие листки и травки, и спросили [говорит по-английски]: “Where are the Germans? We haven’t seen one since [unclear]!” [Неразборчиво] «Немцы? Нет, они бегут перед нами». Мы лезли все на танки. Мы целовали, обнимали эти танки, этих мальчиков. Мы были счастливы. Мы были благодарны им, как никогда. Потом был маленький момент, когда заявили, что немцы приходят в...ммм...Вуарон, что они по дороге из Гренобля в Вуарон бегут. Все разбежались. Но всё-таки трёхцветный флаг остался на церкви, на всех окнах. Через полчаса паника улеглась, и мы тогда ходили по кофейням и обнимали и целовали всех американских солдат, которые с нами были. Мы их поили водкой, мы не знали, что с ними делать. Мы были пьяны от счастья. Они—одинаково пьяны.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво, очень тихо]
Fira Monk: Все. Они бежали сломя голову. Нам рассказывали друзья наши, жившие в Вуароне...в Гренобле, что 21 ночью они слышали странный грохот. И они поняли, что всё хорошо. Это немцы наскоро запаковывали свои вещи. И никому ни сказав ни слова, начали бежать! [Неразборчиво] И они исчезли. Утром, когда люди встали и вышли на улицу, не было вообще ни одного немца. Ещё не было американцев, но немцев уже не было.
David Boder: Ага.
Fira Monk: И только маки царствовали там. Но везде были, конечно, перестрелки. Было очень много жертв.
David Boder: Маки?
Fira Monk: Да. Очень...слишком много. [Пауза] Ну, а раньше бывали моменты, когда...
David Boder: Ну, а война...?
Fira Monk: А война ещё не окончилась. Париж был освобождён 25 августа, тогда окончилась война.
David Boder: Августа 44-го...?
Fira Monk: . . . 44-го года. Но война продол...44-го!
David Boder: Ну, да.
Fira Monk: Но война-то была...это во Франции уже не было войны. Война продолжалась на севере и в других странах.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Т.е. перемирие было только 8 мая 45-го года. Но я уж тогда была в Тулузе. Меня туда делегировала моя дирекция, чтобы открыть новый...наш старый центр, закрытый немцами, из которого немцы всё увезли. Я уж тогда была в Тулузе. И тогда я видела, что наш маленький Вуарон умеет ещё лучше праздновать победу, чем большие университетские города. Более искренне [Говорит со смехом].
Fira Monk: [Неразборчиво]
David Boder: Так. Теперь скажите-ка мне [пауза]...эээ...скажите мне вот что: Вы же интервьюировали очень много displaced persons—беженцев, так сказать, [неразборчиво] сразу после войны, то, что мне не удалось сделать.
Fira Monk: Да. Я...
David Boder: Дайте мне какие-нибудь моменты или дайте мне картину от..., лучше сказать, картины, отдельных случаев, которые, Вы думаете, было особенно важно или интересно, так сказать, запечатлеть.
Fira Monk: Я скажу, что было очень много...я работала в Тулузе в [говорит название организации по-французски]—это был центр...приёмочный центр возвращающихся депортированных и военнопленных. И я там говорила со многими. Эээ...к сожалению, евреев депортированных было очень мало. Я нашла всего десять человек. Но потом ко мне в бюро начали приходить разные молодые люди, которые не возвращались [неразборчиво] в Тулузу, а через другие города и хотели у нас получить работу. И вот с некоторыми из них...например, был такой...
David Boder: Вы мне лучше скажите, дайте мне что-нибудь о не евреях. Какие это были [неразборчиво]?
Fira Monk: А! Вот я Вам щас расскажу. Не евреи были искл...почти все—99%, можно сказать,—политические. Это были коммунисты, социалисты и резистанцы. Это подпольные работники. Я могу говорить с уверенностью только о Вуароне, потому что это был тот городок, где я прожила...эээ...с 42-го по 44-ый год—самые тяжёлые моменты. Там был отель—Тарди. Эээ...владельцы имели двух сыновей. Они оба были в Резистанс. Очаровательные молодые, т.е. молодые—одному было 39, другому 36 лет. Их забрали. В одну прекрасную ночь за ними пришли, их депортировали и больше ничего о них не знали. Но позже узнали, что они погибли в Бухенвальде. Так что все те...эээ...секретарь комиссариата был арестован, как я Вам сказала, и депортирован. Второй...этот...Ангельс...как называется...[неразборчиво] [Пауза] Много было [неразборчиво, помехи] был депортирован и расстрелян. Он был расстрелян в Гренобле самом. Очень много, масса молодых людей были отосланы на принудительные работы.
David Boder: Французов?
Fira Monk: Французов. Но Вы знаете, что они посылали туда бесконечное количество французской молодёжи, и те, которые от них убежали, именно бежали в маки. Ведь вначале, когда их отправляли, они думали, что они там будут работать, что они будут получать деньги, [неразборчиво] будут иметь 2 000 франков в месяц—это будет хорошо. Но они будут финансировать, конечно, как всякий себя уважающий француз. Когда оказалось, что они живут там же, в таких же кошмарных условиях как все еврее, т.е. сначала пропускали евреев, потом пропускали неевреев. Там разницы никакой не было. Я говорила с одной молодой девушкой, которая вернулась из...из Аушвица...она была потом в нескольких других лагерях. Она в течение двух месяцев была в борделе там. Она мне это определённо сказала. Она...
David Boder: За что?
Fira Monk: [Неразборчиво] Вы знаете, я им не ставлю вопросов, этим людям. Я им...я даю им говорить, потому что я не хочу, чтобы они думали, что я любопытна. Это ведь было бы больное любопытство их спрашивать. [Неразборчиво, очень тихо]. И вот одна из них мне сказала: «Я не знаю, как Вы на меня будете смотреть. Я провела два месяца в борделе. И я спаслась только благодаря тому, что в меня влюбился один молодой немец». Она каждые четверть часа пропускала другого немца, и четверть часа отдыха. Если немец у неё задерживался на 5 минут дольше, стучали в дверь.
David Boder: Так вот, дайте всё-таки мне это выяснить. Когда я спросил об этом в...Бухенвальде, мне говорили, что это разрешили в Бухенвальде, и что все проститутки там были нееврейки, потому что немцы считали расеншанде.
Fira Monk: Да.
David Boder: Как же тут еврейская девица попала в бордель?
Fira Monk: Я согласна с Вами. Я не знаю. Я могу Вам сказать только то, что мне эта девушка рассказала.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Мне говорила другая, что многие, даже из евреек, думали, попав в бордель, спастись.
Fira Monk: Но, к сожалению, это было не так. Там они могли работать только три месяца. Через три месяца они все почти заболевали. Тогда их расстреливали. Я читала одно письмо, прибывшее из какого-то лагеря, я не помню, из какого. Это письмо потом было напечатано в одной подпольной газете [говорит название по-французски]. И девушка—это польская партизанка...
David Boder: Как называлась газета?
Fira Monk: [Повторяет по-французски] «Христианское свидетельство».
David Boder: Ага.
Fira Monk: И эта девочка писала своей матери в Ниццу: «Мама, я служу матрацем для немецких солдат. Я работаю уже третий месяц. Я больна. Я знаю, что меня расстреляют. Это моё последнее письмо». Я сама видела это письмо.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Ну, а я Вам скажу так, они не хотят об этом рассказывать, и это вполне естественно, потому что не хочется лишний раз [неразборчиво, очень тихо]. Так что если они Вам не говорят, [неразборчиво] что там этого не было. Я могу только повторять то, что они сказали. Ко мне приходил ещё один молодой человек 26 лет. Он мне сказал: «Мадам, я не знаю, как Вы будете на меня смотреть. Я спас свою жизнь только благодаря тому, что я был [неразборчиво]».
David Boder: Женщина?
Fira Monk: Мужчина!
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Молодой мальчик, ему 26 лет.
Fira Monk: Он приехал совершенно [неразборчиво] в смысле физическом, психологическом [неразборчиво]. И он меня умолял: «Что мне сделать? Я хочу стать опять нормальным человеком, меня это преследует». Я ему сказала, что я не могу его обвинять. Наоборот! Я предпочитаю, чтобы он так спас свою жизнь, чем...эээ...какими-нибудь иными гадостями.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: И я его направила в Тулузу к одному психиатру, и его там лечили. Вообщем, его вылечили. Я от него получила, значит, первое письмо после того, как он в первый раз стал ухаживать за дамой, [неразборчиво].
Fira Monk: А потом мне рассказывала девушка, что она видела одну женщину, над которой проводил эксперименты. Один знакомый врач,...эээ...который провёл в этих лагерях тоже несколько лет,—нет, два года он провёл,—там видел эксперименты, когда брали руку и прибивали её на голову. Когда вспрыскивали...
David Boder: Руку что?
Fira Monk: Руку прибивали к голове или к спине.
David Boder: И...
Fira Monk: Потому что можно было!
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Потому что отрывают лапку правую, но человек живёт. Он видел женщин, которым вспрыскивали се...семена разных животных. Он видел женщину, которой вспрыснули семя...эээ...лошади, которая разбухла, как бочка и которая...в буквальном смысле этого слова лопнула.
David Boder: Так. Вспрыснули ей...?
Fira Monk: Вспрыснули ей семя, сделали...эээ...искусственное оплодотворение.
David Boder: Но как же она вспухнула? Она же не могла забеременеть...
Fira Monk: Она не могла зачать. Но условия нормальные. Но они туда залезли и [неразборчиво]. Я Вам расскажу следующее, что они сделали. Это было в Ницце. Там в одной из еврейских семей арестовали 4 человек, и там была девочка. Маленькая девочка 12 лет. Не еврейка, нет. Француженка маленькая. И она пришла домой через три дня. Её спрашивают: «Ну, как? Как? Что с тобой делали?» Она говорит: «Ничего. Мне ничего не сделали». Всё-таки родители позвали врача, и врач увидел маленький укол на правой ручке. Он спросил: «Что это такое?» Она говорит: «Ничего не знаю. Мне дали какое-то вспрыскивание».
David Boder: Сколько лет было девочке?
Fira Monk: 12. Через два дня девочка умерла. [Пауза] Они ей сделали—мне говорил знакомый врач, не знаю, правда это или нет,—что ещё неизвестно [неразборчиво, помехи].
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 112. The interviewee is Fira Monk [unclear, technical tape disruption]. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.
David Boder: This is apparently Spool 9-113, 9-dash-1-1-3 [pronounces separately]. The original identification as Spool 114 is apparently incorrect. Boder, Chicago. October, 1950.
David Boder: This is Spool 114. Paris, September the 7th, 1946. We continue from Spool 111 and 112. The interviewee is Ms. Fira Monk, an executive secretary...ah...of the Paris office of the ORT.
David Boder: [In Russian] Фира, скажите мне вот что. Значит, Вы мне говорили о известных случаях, которые...или известные истории, которые Вы слышали от тех возвратившихся депорти, которых Вы интервьюировали. Эээ...имеете ли Вы какие-нибудь другие?
Fira Monk: Я сказала...у меня очень много есть, но я дала этим людям слово, что я не буду рассказывать.
David Boder: Вы ж не называете имён!
Fira Monk: Я не знаю. Но Вы знаете, у меня такое [неразборчиво], что я обещала...трудно сказать. Я Вам скажу только одно: что все эти люди всегда возвращаются к тому же. Что это было страшно, что это было так, что ни одна человеческая фантазия не может себе представить. Ложились спать рядом с человеком, ночью случилось, что ваш сосед холодеет и утром ваш сосед начинал разлагаться. Но вы не обращали на этого...на это внимания. И спали рядом с ним. Потому что его порция хлеба продолжала выдаваться. И тогда люди дрались за кусок хлеба. Я говорила с одним мальчиком. Ему 16 лет. Он мне сказал: «Слушайте, мои руки обагрены кровью. И это полицейская кровь немцев, на них есть еврейская кровь. Я убивал людей за кусок хлеба. Я убивал людей за лишнюю одежду». Я ему сказала: «Я не могу тебя винить, потому что я не знаю, как бы я была на твоём месте. Ты должен об этом забыть». Он говорит: «Нет, забыть нельзя. [Неразборчиво] я должен помнить». [Неразборчиво] эти страшные вещи. Я думаю, что Вы их достаточно слышали. Есть же люди, которые забывали. [Неразборчиво]
David Boder: Я бы хотел Ваше мнение. Я думаю, что женщины не всегда были очень откровенны со мной. Я имею такие принципы. Я думаю, что они были более откровенны с Вами.
Fira Monk: Да.
David Boder: А с другой стороны, это необычайно важно, чтобы эти факты записались не потому, что...эээ...в виде науки немедленно можно всё брать на веру...но они могут служить указателями или...эээ...так сказать...эээ...директивами для дальнейших исследований.
Fira Monk: Я понимаю. Я Вам скажу, что большинство женщин, с которыми я говорила, это в большей части молодые девушки. Они мне говорили все: «Мы не вернулись в таком виде, в каком мы уехали». Т.е. они, очевидно, все, не смотря на расеншанде, не смотря на запреты об общении с еврейскими женщинами...ведь в начале, до того, как их брили для того, чтобы они приобретали нечеловеческий вид, они ещё были теми же хорошенькими молодыми девушками, которых забирали. Я понимаю, что до определённого периода ими всеми пользовались немцы, а потом, когда они...если они не заболевали или если они проходили определённый стаж, то они превращались в тех же вьючных животным, в тех же рабов. Это бывали лагери как [неразборчиво], где женщины работали, а они работали как скоты. Они—старые арестанты говорили,—они до того воняли, на них были все эти паразиты, что на них никто не смотрел, к ним близко нельзя было подступиться. Так что я не думаю, что такая женщина могла соблазнить самого незадачливого немецкого солдата.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Но я думаю, что боль...самый...что больший процент молодых девушек всё-таки прошёл через именно это унижение. Потому что они все мне говорили: «Есть такая болезнь, такая болезнь». Я их отправляла к врачам, я часто с ними ходила к врачу. И большей частью, это были венерические болезни.
David Boder: С другой стороны, мне кажется, что немцы необычайно следили за тем, чтобы их солдаты не имели бы венерических болезней?!
Fira Monk: Да. Они ведь каждые два дня...эти женщины из этих домов...они осматривались врачами. Там были замечательные гигиенические условия. Стояла вода, и после того немцам давалось чистое полотенце. Чистая вода не давалась. Все знали, что, не смотря на полотенце, через воду шла зараза. Ведь солдат, до того, как он входил к женщине, получал специальную пилюлю.
David Boder: Какую?
Fira Monk: А я не знаю.
David Boder: В смысле, это медицинское...
Fira Monk: Да, да, да. Какое-то привентивное.
David Boder: Ага, привентивное.
Fira Monk: Да. Но [неразборчиво] очень трудно. Даже со мной эти женщины...они как-то закрываются. Я...я Вам говорю, что я их не спрашивала. Но когда тема приходила, я им говорила: «Вы мне говорите как на духу, считайте меня своей сестрой, своей матерью, если они были моложе меня. Говорите со мной так, чтоб вам стало легче. Скажите. Ведь иногда, когда поплачешь, станет легче». И некоторые из них говорили [неразборчиво] сказала, приблизительно всё одно и то же: [Неразборчиво] «один солдат, другой держал», «четыре солдата за руки и за ноги», «возле него лежал пулемёт», «всего 12 человек». Очень многие были изнасилованы после. К сожалению...
David Boder: После чего?
Fira Monk: После событий в Ницце. Даже американцами, англичанами и русскими. Это мне говорили женщины. Я думаю, что я могу им верить. На войне так и человек приобретает животный вид и животные повадки. Мне говорила одна французская девушка молодая—её депортировали за политические убеждения—и когда её освободили, она была освобождена русскими, её изнасиловало 25 человек. [Пауза] Она была в Тулузе. Её направили потом в больницу. [Неразборчиво] направил её в больницу, и мне говорили—я этого не видела,—мне говорили, что ей нужно было сделать вообще операции, нужно было всё удалить. Она [неразборчиво]. Мужчины тоже, вообще, у мужчин гораздо труднее. Вы знаете, что и как. Но то, что меня страшно удивляло, что в лагерях были случаи рождения детей. Правда, если жен...дети рождались, немцы приказывали их, конечно, удушивать.
David Boder: Может быть, это было рождение детей от женщин, которые забеременовали раньше?
Fira Monk: Да. Но одно время тогда туда не депортировали беременных женщин. Их прятали...
David Boder: А они могли не знать [неразборчиво]
Fira Monk: Нет, многие даже вообще фальшиво доказывали, что они беременные. [Пауза] Но бывали случаи, которые женщины уже сидели там два года, рожали там, на месте, ребёнка, и этого ребёнка приканчивали тут же. Некоторым, очень маленькому проценту, удалось спасти их младенца. Я знаю одну женщину, которая уехала не беременной, и которая вернулась с ребёнком оттуда. Я никак не могла добиться, каким образом она вообще забеременела. Я просто поставила вопрос: «Скажите мне, каким образом, если мужские...мужские и женские лагеря были в самом далеке друг от друга, как они всё-таки могли пробиться к друг другу». Она улыбнулась и сказала: «Знаешь, когда кого-нибудь любишь, то там нет никаких преград». Оказывается, она там имела человека, с которым она вернулась.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Но я до сегодня не могу понять, [неразборчиво]. А другие...я...во-первых, они там...я думаю, что они там не могли беременеть лишь потому, что они моментально...что у них моментально пропадала менструация.
David Boder: Как...я уже слышал об этом.
Fira Monk: Да. Я Вам щас расскажу.
David Boder: Да.
Fira Monk: Даже в лагере Гюрсе, когда...
David Boder: Каком лагере?
Fira Monk: Гюрс. Это на юге Франции, возле испанской границы тоже. Сюда сажали женщин—австриек, немок, полек. Это уже с 39-го года.
David Boder: Не евреев?
Fira Monk: Не евреев и евреев. Это был общий лагерь, хотя когда его освобождали, евреи там оставались.
David Boder: Угу.
Fira Monk: И вот в первую очередь у женщин прекращалась менструация. Я тогда работала вместе с ОЗЕ, как секретарша ОРТа [неразборчиво]. И мы решили им послать всякие лекарства, и конечно, большое количество ваты и предохранительных [неразборчиво]. И мне одна приятельница ответила: “Не посылай. Мне совершенно ничего не нужно, все стоят здесь». Я боюсь, что это какая-то нервная связка или же питание недостаточное. Но мне сказала одна девушка, которая вернулась из депортации, что когда она туда приехала, ей дали выпить какую-то белую жидкость.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Другая мне рассказала, что ей дали выпить какую-то красную жидкость. [Пауза] И ещё одна женщина сказала, что ей сделали вспрыскивание в ногу.
Fira Monk: И у них моментально прекращалася кровь.
David Boder: Моментально же не может быть?!
Fira Monk: Т.е. в течение месяца уже ничего не было.
David Boder: И это что? Осталось навсегда?
Fira Monk: Нет. Эээ...почти у всех это вернулось. У некоторых это было хуже, у некоторых лучше, но большинство...все, которых я спрашивала через несколько месяцев после возвращения, они мне говорили, что стали опять уже нормальными женщинами.
David Boder: Т.е....как это...они не менструировали в лагере?
Fira Monk: Ни в одном.
David Boder: Тогда это может быть...
Fira Monk: Я думаю...
David Boder: . . . вода, они голодные...
Fira Monk: От голода. Это может быть от голода, может быть эти жуткие условия, этот холод, быть всё может. То, что им давали эти...эээ...всякие жидкости пить или вспрыскивать—я не знаю, что это такое. Можно сказать...они простые женщины [неразборчиво] из еврейского гетто. Молодые, которые вообще не знают, что с ними происходит. Я никак не могла добиться, [неразборчиво] с врачами мне удалось говорить потом и вряд ли какой-нибудь нормальный думающий врач мог узнать, что такое могли дать. Ещё я не знала. Но, во всяком случае, они не...[неразборчиво] он не хотят говорить. Они [неразборчиво], мне сказала одна ученица нашей школы. Она говорит: «Я никак не могу понять, как я всё это пережила...» Ей 19 лет, она была депортирована 6 лет. Она была в Аушвице, она была в Мальтхаузене, она была в [неразборчиво]. Вообщем, она проделала весь цикл. Она безумно [неразборчиво]. Она весит, кажется, 85 кило. И это совершенно неестественный вес. И она мне говорит: «Я никак не могу понять, каким образом я осталась жива после...всего того, что я пережила». Я ей скажу: «Скажи мне, тебя немцы трогали? Они с тобой что-нибудь сделали? Потому что, если тебя изнасиловали, я с тобой пойду к врачу, тебя вылечат». А она говорит: «Значит, я об этом даже не хочу говорить». [Неразборчиво] Да или нет? Я же...если с ней что-нибудь произошло...она не хочет мне рассказать, я не знаю. [Пауза]
David Boder: Скажите...скажите вот что: Вы говорили про какого-то сына сиониста, который [неразборчиво]. Кто это?
Fira Monk: Это Гринбаум.
David Boder: Гринбаум. Что Вы знаете?
Fira Monk: Я знаю только то, что мне рассказывали. Он был депортирован как коммунист. Он всегда со своим отцом спорил на политические темы. Его отец—очень видный деятельный сионист. Он...
David Boder: Отец его в Палестине?
Fira Monk: Отец его в Палестине. Сидит, арестованный англичанами.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: А сын здесь сидит, арестованный французскими властями.
David Boder: Так. А в качестве чего?
Fira Monk: В качестве негодяя, потому что он вернулся из депортации, был депортирован. Его отец был начальник. Когда он вернулся, отец был счастлив. И это было здесь, в каком-то офисе, я даже не знаю точно, в каком. Но молодой человек пришёл к своему отцу, счастье было очень велико. И там было два господина, вернувшихся из депортации. Когда они увидели молодого Гринбаума, они на него напали и избили его как собаку, и сказали, что он негодяй. Оказалось, что он был капо. Капо—это был такой заведующий.
David Boder: Ну, да. Но было же много капо.
Fira Monk: Было очень много капо. Но бывали всякие капо. Мне рассказали интересный ещё случай, что там было три капо: один голландец, один француз, один еврей. Немецкий еврей. И—это мне, к сожалению, не очень хорошо рассказать, но это нужно,—и вот в силу какой-то [неразборчиво] попало колечко. Тогда взяли всех женщин в лагере, и их осмотрели гинекологически. Осматривали эти три капо.
David Boder: Это были женщины-капо?
Fira Monk: Нет, это было трое мужчин.
David Boder: Ах, эти три...трое мужчины осматривали...
Fira Monk: . . . осматривали женщин. Арестованных женщин. И француз, и бельгиец ничего не нашли, а еврей вытащил колечко.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Тогда велели ему осмотреть всех остальных. Я не знаю, вытащил ли он и другие вещи или нет, мне об этом не говорили. И это видел француз, который вернулся. И тогда [неразборчиво] “Вы евреи». Предложили ему папиросу, дали ему кусочек шоколада. Он поднялся в [неразборчиво]. Бельгиец был убит. Как он был убит? А француз оказался [неразборчиво], на ней были такие шрамы, что на это было страшно смотреть.
David Boder: Это был один из этих капо?
Fira Monk: Один из этих капо.
David Boder: Ну, да.
Fira Monk: Ну, вот. Я видела испанцев. Там было очень большое количество испанских социалистов депортировано. Те, которые бежали из фашистской Испании во время войны, сидели здесь, на юге Франции в разных лагерях. И потом их скопом отправили. И вот мне один—это было на вокзале с...т.е....ммм...на приёмочной в Тулузе—он снял свою рубаху, снял свои брюки и показал мне своё тело. У него на груди шёл шрам в три пальца шириной, в полпальца глубиной. Это его полоснуло лопатой. На спине у него была дырка, в которую свободно можно было поместить маленький палец, доходила до рёбер. Это его ударили киркой. У него было двенадцать огнестрельных ран, или больше—я даже не знаю. У него не было, что называется, живого места на теле. Это потому что он, как коммунист, он попал в арестантский лагерь, в котором сидели—это было [неразборчиво]—и это на него там нашли лопатой, киркой, пулемётами, всем, чем хотите. Он чудом выжил. Мне говорили об одной женщине, которая была депортирована, и она выжила. А выжила она следующим образом. Её втолкнули в газовую камеру первой, за ней втолкнули остальных. Она упала, когда начался газ. И на неё навалились остальные трупы. И когда они начали выгребать, она, правда, была в бессознательном состоянии, но она была жива. Эта женщина теперь здесь. Там происходили самые невероятные вещи. Вот мне рассказали об одной женщине,—она из Тулузы была [неразборчиво]. Её забрали с ребёнком, которому было 8 месяцев. Она вернулась с ребёнком 17 месяцев. Каким образом она его спасла, она и сама не знает. Она его держала в мусоре, под юбкой, и вообщем, она его кормила, чем хотите. И вскармливала его этим кошмарным, простите за выражение, супом. Это была вода, помои, в которых плавало несколько листочков. Мне рассказывали мальчики, что одного из них приставили следить за собаками. Вы знаете, там были собаки специальные, дрессированные. И одна собака чуть не сдохла с голоду, потому что она съела её похлёбку. Он ей отдавал свою похлёбку. Я разговаривала с одним молодым человеком. Его фальшивое имя было Жебер. [Неразборчиво]: «Я не хочу [неразборчиво] собаки». «Такая чудная маленькая собака». Он говорит: «Я не могу видеть собак». Я говорю: «Почему?» Он говорит: «После того, как я видел своими глазами, как собака растерзала двоих детей, а вы хотите, чтобы я когда-нибудь в жизни трогал собаку?!» Я ему говорю: «[неразборчиво] специально дрессированную собаку!» А он: «Всё равно, сколько собаку не дрессируй...» Я говорю: «Вы не можете смотреть на людей? [Неразборчиво]” А он говорит: «Люди—[неразборчиво]» [Длинная пауза] Ну, а те, которые вернулись сюда...я Вам скажу, они все, конечно, изувечены на всю жизнь. Мне говорил директор одного детского дома в [неразборчиво], что ночью у них ужасные кошмары.
David Boder: У детей?
Fira Monk: У детей, да. Они кричат, их нужно отпаивать бромом, у них бывают такие...эээ...припадки ребелье—протеста. Вдруг они не хотят чего-то делать. Я один раз пришла к ним в этот детский дом просить у них маленькое [неразборчиво] атлетическое. Я, значит, прихожу и прошу, чтоб они для наших учеников сделали маленький спектакль. Я им говорю: «Господа, в субботу мы устраиваем вечер. Вы наши желанные гости. Я была бы вам очень благодарна, если бы вы нам рассказали стихи, потанцевали». «Нет, мы не хотим». Ну, я им говорю: «Вы знаете, я приехала специально из Парижа вас спросить». «Нет, мы не хотим. Ни за что. Что такое? Какие распоряжения, были какие-то?» «Пожалуйста». Я была со своим коллегой [неразборчиво], я говорю ему: «Слушай [неразборчиво], а если поговорить с ними по-человечески, как брат с братом?» Он пошёл. Он говорит: «Зачем вы обижаете [неразборчиво]? Она же приехала специально из Парижа. [Неразборчиво] Почему вы себя так ведёте?» Поднялся ужасный шум. Что там происходило, у меня появилось ощущение, что они его могут убить. Через 5 мин. вдруг так [неразборчиво] так это прошло, они ко мне подошли, они меня уже обнимали, они уже меня целовали. Они в субботу приехали. У нас был один из самых лучших вечеров нашего клуба. Они были совершенно изумительно: они пели песенки, они танцавали, они импровизировали. И все были счастливы—и исполнители, и слуша...эээ...эти...слушатели. Так что, они [неразборчиво]. И живут они ещё теперь в ужасных условиях. Еврейские организации делают всё, что они хотят, но, к сожалению, чистоты нету. Тут есть один дом, в котором они живут. Там безумная грязь, и они мне говорили: «Мы вышли из лагеря для того, чтобы попасть во второй лагерь». Там клопов больше, чем...ммм...счастья.
David Boder: Это где? На...
Fira Monk: Ру де Руди. Я не должна этого говорить, потому что...[говорит с улыбкой]
David Boder: Ну, да. Дело, видите ли, вот в чём. Вот, например, я был здесь в одном доме на...Вам всё равно, где...
Fira Monk: Да.
David Boder: . . . и живут так же, как и в Бухенвальде. Неужели нельзя было достать простыней на...?
Fira Monk: Мы не можем иметь простыней, и я Вам скажу, почему. Тут всё продается с пунктами. На чёрном рынке безумно дорого. Мы должны платить по три-четыре тысячи франков за простыню.
David Boder: А...а заказать в Америке?
Fira Monk: У нас будет та же самая простынь из Америки. То, что нам прислали из Америки—это стыд и срам.
David Boder: Угу.
Fira Monk: Нас поставили в очередь в комити. Мы получили...ОРТ получил...
David Boder: Этот какой комити?
Fira Monk: Комити [говорит название по-французски]—это международный комитет помощи беженцам.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Мы получили два эшелона вещей. Это уже были разобранные, сортированные вещи. Я провела полтора месяца на сортировке сортированных вещей. Меня искусали блохи. Моя коллега отказалась мне помогать. Она говорит, что она задыхается от вони. Я обвязывала себе нос...
David Boder: Из Америки?!
Fira Monk: Из Америки.
David Boder: Мы, например,...когда мы даём вещи, нам говорят: «Давайте всё. Это всё равно будет дезинфицировано, очищено и так далее».
Fira Monk: Так. Да. Но эти вещи были в таком состоянии, что там были пятна: от пота, от менструации, от уборной, от всего, что Вы хотите. Это всё нужно было [неразборчиво]. Кроме того, [неразборчиво] это было в самом безобразном виде. Если я выбрала оттуда 200 платьев из двух эшелонов, так это было много. Вещи...
David Boder: Женских вещей?
Fira Monk: Женских. Для мужчин вообще почти ничего не было. Я должна была раздать половину вещей, да что половину?! 95% вещей я раздала нашему курсу мужских портных, чтобы они учились делать карманы на штанах. Потому что из всего...из всей пары брюк можно было вытащить один карман. Это было безобразие. Это было собрано всеми американскими обществами. Гифт, [неразборчиво] и так далее. Лучше бы они прислали меньше [неразборчиво], а больше лучше вещей.
David Boder: Ну, а тут же военные вещи были? Солдатские вещи? Их нельзя было получить?
Fira Monk: Эээ...Федерация получила несколько раз какие-то вещи, более или менее приличные. Говорили, что они из Аргентины. Особенно они получили хорошие ботинки. Я с них тоже одевала несколько наших молодых людей, которые были совершенно голые.
David Boder: Какая это федерация?
Fira Monk: Федерация еврейских обществ Франции.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Она проделала совершенно изумительную работу во время оккупации. И...затем...депортированные когда приезжали сюда, если они были депортированные из Франции, они получали в офисе 8 тысяч франков наличными и получали кроме того вещи они тоже: костюм, две смены белья и пару обуви.
David Boder: Кто получали эти 8 тысяч франков—французы или какие бы то ни было...?
Fira Monk: Только те, которые были депортированы из Франции.
David Boder: Те получили 8 тысяч и...?
Fira Monk: 8 тысяч наличными,...
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: . . . костюм, пару обучи и две смены белья.
David Boder: 8 тысяч наличными по самому официальному курсу—это приблизительно 70 долларов.
Fira Monk: 70 долларов.
David Boder: Так. И пару что?
Fira Monk: И...пару, значит...костюм,...
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: . . . пару ботинок,...
Fira Monk: . . . и две смены белья.
David Boder: Так. Это были какие, новые вещи?
Fira Monk: Да, это были совершенно новые. Они получали специальные купоны. По этим они могли ходить в магазины. Я даже имела следующий случай: одна женщина вернулась из Равенсбрюка...
David Boder: Т.е. они не должны были платить за эти вещи?
Fira Monk: Как это? Нет, они не платили. Они получали [неразборчиво] и в течение 3 месяцев они имели право на бесплатное лечение. Они получали 15 банок молока сгущённого в месяц, получали двойные...эти...армитационные карточки, продуктовые карточки. Им всё-таки было очень хорошо: вместо 350гр хлеба было 700.
David Boder: Это значит те, которые были депортированы из Франции?
Fira Monk: Двойные...двойные продуктовые карточки получали исключительно все. [Неразборчиво] получали все.
Fira Monk: Так.
David Boder: А франки и...
Fira Monk: А франки...деньги получали только те, которые были депортированы из Франции.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Конечно, взяли...
David Boder: Ну, если...если, например, возвращался какой-нибудь департи, который был депортирован из Польши...
Fira Monk: Он этого не имел.
David Boder: Он не имел франки, но он получал усиленные продукты.
Fira Monk: Да.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Fira Monk: Но он должен был платить за продукты, которые он покупал.
David Boder: О!
Fira Monk: Но у него была двойная карточка.
David Boder: Двойная карточка, да?
Fira Monk: Да. Кроме того, они получали от организации помощи депортированным, они получали вместо...ммм...они получали кило сахару, 15 банок сгущённого молока, столько-то салатного масла, 500 грамм масла.
David Boder: Бесплатно?
Fira Monk: Бесплатно. Я даже ходила помогала одному господину, который не мог носить тяжёлых вещей. Я ему это всё принесла домой—это был очень большой и очень тяжёлый пакет.
David Boder: Так. Это французское правительство...?
Fira Monk: Это французское. Это министерство [неразборчиво] давало им.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Ну, а что касается жизненных условий, то я вообще не могу обвинить никого, потому что тут жилищный кризис очень велик. Платяной кризис ещё больше. Заработные возможности очень малы. То, что люди зарабатывают, не соответствует прожиточному минимуму. Так что я совершенно не могу обвинять организации, которые имеют столько людей у себя на голове, [неразборчиво] что человеку нужно, по крайней мере, 8 тысяч франков в месяц, чтобы он жил более или менее прилично, а организация может дать максимум две тысячи—это самое большее [неразборчиво]. Так что как хотите. И не все люди в состоянии работать. Нужно считаться с тем, что они приехали в страшном физическом состоянии.
David Boder: Эээ...скажите, Фира, вот что: что, Вы думаете, получится из всех этих людей, которые тут в ОРТе и во всех этих организациях- дети и прочее?
Fira Monk: Я Вам скажу. ОРТ—единственная организация, которая не воспитывает...этих...ммм...попрошаек. Мы им даём возможность работать и возможность зарабатывать. Мы им даём в руки труд. Я думаю, что это самый ценный багаж, который вообще можно дать в руки молодому человеку. К сожалению, очень многие из них пока, я подчёркиваю именно, что пока, потому что я надеюсь, что это измениться со временем, они пока вообще считают, что работать не нужно. Что организации на то и есть, чтобы их содержать. И это вполне естественно. Эти люди выбиты совершенно из колеи. Их забрали, когда им было 14-15 лет. Они жили в таких нечеловеческих условиях. Их слишком заставляли работать. Они слишком тяжело работали ни за что и ни про что. И вот теперь, когда им говорят: «Ты должен научиться какому-нибудь ремеслу, чтобы работать», у них первая реакция: «Как?! Работать?! Мы достаточно работали. Теперь на нас должны работать». Но постепенно это всё-таки стушовывается. Мы им даём всё, что мы можем дать. Мы им даём любовь, ласку; мы им даём [неразборчиво]. Наши педагоги подходят к каждому из молодых, которые у нас учатся, как к своему собственному ребёнку. Мы их называем нашими детьми. Мы их любим, мы их искренне любим. Мы следим за ними не только в смысле образования, мы следим за ними в смысле физическом и в смысле моральном. Дети научаються любить этот дом. Мы устраиваем для них все развлечения—у нас есть клуб. Они выходят, они занимаются спортом, Мы направляем их к чтению, мы обучаем их различным языкам. И вот дети мало-помалу втягиваются в эту нормальную жизнь. Я их всех называю детьми именно потому, что я считаю, что они потеряли столько лет, столько времени—они остаются на том же уровне, на котором они ушли. Есть мальчик, которого...или девочка...которого забрали 14 лет, который за эти 5 лет ничего, кроме плохого, не приобрёл. Немцы ведь сделали всё, что могли, чтобы уничтожить в них человеческий облик. И теперь, когда мы видим, что дети превращаются, что они начинают любить своё ремесло...У нас есть один мальчик. Он сделал себе аппарат. Это...
David Boder: Это какой аппарат?
Fira Monk: Это...это радио.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: И аппарат был назначен на выставку. Мы не могли его ещё отдать. Он приходил и просил разрешение приходить каждое воскресение послушать свой аппарат. И ясно, мы ему дали разрешение. Наша дворничиха давала ему ключ, он заходил в ателье радио, он садился, он закрывал окна, и он слушал свой собственный аппарат.
David Boder: А вот скажите мне вот что: где бы эти мальчики хотели бы работать во Франции? Как с этими разрешениями работать для иммигрантов?
Fira Monk: Разрешение работать следующее. Когда иностранец хочет получить работу, его патрон должен ему выдать свидетельство, что он его принимает на службу на таких-то и таких-то условиях. С этим свидетельством идут в министерство труда. Посылается оттуда человек, который делает анкету о том, правда...
David Boder: Исследование?
Fira Monk: Исследование....правда ли это, и в 98% получается разрешение. Особенные поблажки теперь делаются именно беженцам. Я слышала позавчера следующее. Будто бы Франция согласна впустить обратно ровно такое же количество иностранных беженцев, как были отсюда забраны, т.е. 120 тысяч человек. [Пауза]
David Boder: Т.е. как? Сколько людей было забрано?
Fira Monk: Да.
David Boder: Это беженцев было забрано?
Fira Monk: Столько людей.
David Boder: Да.
Fira Monk: Т.е. беженцев было забрано 90 тысяч, а французских евреев—30 тысяч.
David Boder: Так. 30 тысяч. Скажите, сколько осталось евреев во Франции?
Fira Monk: Если я не ошибаюсь, 14 тысяч. Я не знаю точно.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Fira Monk: Да.
David Boder: Так вот. Скажите, из всех тех, которых увезли работать в Германию французов, всего 120 тысяч не вернулось?!
Fira Monk: Нет! Забрали евреев 120 тысяч.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: А французов забрали около полумиллиона.
Fira Monk: И из евреев вернулось 6 тысяч. Из 6 тысяч детей, которых забрали, вернулось 60, а из 120 тысяч взрослых вернулось 6 тысяч. А французов забирали на принудительные работы.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво] И французы готовы теперь впустить 100 тысяч евреев?!
Fira Monk: Да. 120 тысяч.
David Boder: 120 тысяч евреев?
Fira Monk: Беженцев. Евреев-беженцев.
David Boder: Из евреев?
Fira Monk: Да, еврейских беженцев.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Было об...я надеюсь, что это правда. Я не знаю.
David Boder: Это приблизительно то количество, которое [неразборчиво] теперь в Палестине?
Fira Monk: Да. Я не знаю, я боюсь сказать об этом что-нибудь. Мне об этом говорили. Я хочу на днях зайти к одному...
David Boder: Это слух?
Fira Monk: Это не слух. Это мне сказал человек, которые очень часто мне давал правильные сведения.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Я хочу на днях зайти к одному господину из министерства, и я хочу его спросить, правда ли это. Потому что это было бы очень интересно. Тогда для ОРТа начинается здесь очень большая и осень интересная работа. Потому что большинство из них нуждается в [неразборчиво, очень тихо].
David Boder: И значит, они их впустят? Это не то, что временно. Они им позволят тут жить и тут устроиться.
Fira Monk: Да, они смогут здесь жить. Те, которые захотят иммигрировать в Палестину или в Америку, ясно, Франция не будет ставить палки в колёса, если эти страны их не оставят. Так. Во Франции вообще живётся им свободно. Что хочу, то и делаю.
David Boder: Да. Т.е. как? Человек, который тут временно, может тут работать?
Fira Monk: Теперь...теперь, если приезжает какой-нибудь беженец—значит, либо депортированный, либо оставшийся из Польши или из других стран, он приезжает сюда в качестве [неразборчиво] в Америку, например.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: И он должен ждать 6 месяцев.
David Boder: Угу.
Fira Monk: Тогда он просит временное право на работу.
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: И он получает его. Вчера у меня был в бюро один господин, который хочет научиться делать сумки. И ему на это тоже...потому что в ОРТ ему тоже нужно право на работу. Потому что...
David Boder: Т.е. в то время, когда он учится, ему надо право на работу?
Fira Monk: Да. Да, да, потому что он взрослый. Он не может сойти за подмастерье [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Так.
Fira Monk: Он должен иметь право на работу, потому что его хозяин обязан ему платить.
Fira Monk: Для того, чтобы не вышло, что он сидит на шее у французского правительства.
David Boder: Угу.
Fira Monk: И хозяин ему даст свидетельство, что он у него обучается ремеслу и получает за это половинный тариф. И он получит [неразборчиво] рабочую карточку [неразборчиво].
David Boder: А скажите, как в [неразборчиво] союзе относятся к этим беженцам и заботе об этих беженцах?
Fira Monk: Они всячески их поддерживают. Они стараются им найти работу, они очень их защищают, они защищают их интересы. Они всеми силами стараются, чтобы эти люди забыли всё то, через что они прошли.
David Boder: А что, разве во Франции нет безработицы теперь? Эти проходящие конкурируют с ними?
Fira Monk: Я Вам скажу, есть отрасли, в которых вакансии нет, безработицы вообще. Но есть другие...эээ...французы вообще...эээ...такой настоящей безработицы, как вы её понимаете в Америке, вот идеальной...идеальной безработицы—у нас этого нет.
David Boder: Скажите мне ещё один вопрос: что тут за недоразумение происходит с квартирами?
Fira Monk: С квартирами...
David Boder: С возвращением квартир тем, которые были депортированы?
Fira Monk: [Пауза] Это тоже немножечко относится к области антисемитизма. Потому что квартиры, которые...в которых раньше жили евреи, которые...или вообще те евреи депортированные, были заняты во время их отсутствия кем-нибудь другим. Теперь. Вышел, к сожалению, закон, что если в этой квартире сидит француз, а вернувшийся—иностранец, то иностранец не имеет права выселить француза, потому что француз у себя в стране, а иностранец—только гость.
David Boder: Его гость?
Fira Monk: Его...
David Boder: А французским евреям возвращают вообще?
Fira Monk: Да, возвращают. Гораздо больше. Хотя у меня есть один приятель-врач. Он французский еврей. Его квартира была занята. Он был в Швейцарии всё время. Его квартира была занята, его квартира занята, его квартира будет занята, и он сидит у какой-то знакомой дамы, никак не может найти, где поселиться, потому что нужно отдать очень большие суммы. Это послевоенное время [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Т.е. как «стоит больших денег»? [Неразборчиво]
Fira Monk: Нет.
David Boder: Квартир нет?
Fira Monk: Квартир нет. Разрушили очень много домов. Очень много беженцев за пределами Франции, которые ещё не могут вернуться. [Неразборчиво] большое количество домов переделаны в военные учреждения, даже вашими американскими.
David Boder: Так. Ну, госпожа Фира Монк, это было очень интересный рапорт, и я думаю, после того, как мы тут сделаем транскрипцию...эээ...разберём это, так сказать, по косточкам, у нас останется очень много...нет, не Вас...очень много важного материала.
Fira Monk: Спасибо.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with Ms. Fira Monk, an executive secretary in the offices of ORT for a number of years...ahh...who passed the whole time of the crisis in France. We are having here a...first-hand information about several situations in France, and to some extent some data from some leads from people who she has interviewed. Paris, September the 7th, 1946. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording. Thank you very much. [Pause]
Fira Monk: Thank you very much.
David Boder: Now is there anything you want to say in English to the Americans?
Fira Monk: I would like only to say that...
David Boder: From the people of the ORT?
Fira Monk: From the people of the ORT—a “Hello!”—I don’t know we say it. [unintelligible]
David Boder: Yes, well. What do you think should the Americans do for the ORT?
Fira Monk: Everything they can. And everything they should. They saw our work here and I hope that they liked it. And I hope they will continue to help us to do a better work.
David Boder: Do a better job?
Fira Monk: A better job, yes. [Unclear] we have too much happening [unclear, very soft voice]
David Boder: Adopt in what sense?
Fira Monk: To ah...their father and mother to take them home. If they can...
David Boder: To take them to America?
Fira Monk: To take them to America. To take them in their houses. And to give for them a real father and mother. I think it would be best [unintelligible].
David Boder: This concludes Spool 114 [incorrect, this is Spool 113]. I am reading in the sign of now [?] by checking the spool in Chicago. October, the 9th, 1950. The spool...this spool was somehow miscataloged and it had the name of Miss Kuechler. We’ll check on the next spool and see whether Miss Kuechler starts on that one. Project MH156, Boder.